well every Disney cember we try to look
at the best that Disney has to offer
this year we're gonna go the opposite
route if you're younger you might have
noticed all these sequels that seem to
pop up too popular Disney films that
don't really seem to be as good this is
because as hand-drawn films were
starting to phase out and CG films were
starting to phase in Disney didn't
always have a lot to do for their
hand-drawn department at least nothing
that made that much of profit however
that seemed to change though not
necessarily for the best with the
direct-to-dvd series for whatever reason
kids just love to see what was gonna
happen next in these movies that really
didn't need any continuing stories and
they got a reputation pretty fast of
being the worst
you name it Lion King Aladdin Pocahontas
even The Hunchback of Notre 'adam got a
sequel as they seem to make more and
more money they pushed him out faster
and faster and well they have a
reputation for being some of Disney's
worst material in recent years for a
long time people have been asking me to
look these over and by god I didn't want
to but you know what I'm an optimist and
I'm gonna hold out hope that there's at
least one just one good sequel out there
is it a fool's wish maybe but I'm
determined to get through all of them to
see if they're as bad as everybody says
they are
I get a feeling they're right but I
should judge for myself even though
there's surprisingly enough films to
almost fill the entire month there's
still one or two that I have available
yet so I'll fill those in with not
sequels but still direct-to-dvd movies
that they made is there somewhere a
diamond in the rough to be found well
all through the month of December I'm
gonna find out because you demanded it
this is Disney cember direct-to-dvd
sequels I hope you appreciate what I do
for you
so let's go to where this all started I
remember I got the VHS of fox and the
hound as soon as you open it up there
was a little pamphlet that said one of
the greatest villains was coming back
you opened it up and you saw Disney's
the return of Jafar
holy smokes to a little kid this was
amazing Aladdin was one of the biggest
films that ever came out at that time
and Disney never really did any sequels
apart from the rescuers down under so we
were beyond excited to see another
Aladdin movie on the big screen as more
time went by though we realized it
wasn't gonna be on the big screen it was
gonna be direct a VHS ok it was still an
Aladdin sequel and it was done by Disney
it still has to be pretty good right
well then we saw the trailer for it and
man there is a serious downgrade it was
pretty obvious from the first frame what
this was this was Disney trying to cash
in on a popular movie which they've done
before but not usually with a sequel and
not usually with such a difference in
animation so yeah the hype died down
pretty quickly but I'm still kind of
interested in seeing it after all it was
Aladdin and we want to know what evil
scheme Jafar had up his sleeve the film
centers around Aladdin get used to his
new palace life and apparently still
unable to put on a shirt when Diago the
parrot escapes from Jafar's lamp and
tosses it away trying to convince
Aladdin in the gang day he's changed for
good even though he really just wants a
new position of power on top of it the
genie returns to a sort of rabble Eames
didn't come back to voice in this time
and it really shows they got dan
Castellaneta the voice of Homer Simpson
to do him instead to be fair it's not a
bad choice he can do a pretty good
impression but so much of the genie was
Robin Williams just doing his improv and
nobody's as good as him so immediately
it's a little distracting but Jafar
returns as well as a thief played by
Jason Alexander accidentally releases
him and Jafar as the genie promises to
grant him his wishes if he follows
through with his revenge
so Jafar plans his evil scheme by
framing a lead and making it look like
he killed the Sultan all while locking
up everybody else away the plot in
general is not that bad and to its
credit of Farr's revenge
actually a pretty good one but nothing
feels as fleshed out as the original in
fact Aladdin doesn't even seem like the
focus it feels more like the focuses on
Diago he's the one that has the story
arc he's the one that's torn between two
places but in terms of what made the
original Aladdin so enjoyable and
continuing it here a lot of it just
doesn't transfer over whether they
didn't have the time or the budget or
whatever it just feels really rushed
aladdin and Jasmine don't have much
chemistry the genies not really that
funny the animation though I know
they're trying just can't compete with
the incredible colors and movement that
the first one had even the songs aren't
as hummable and yeah way too many of
them are given to Gilbert Godfrey
because that's a voice I want to hear
put to music I remember when my brother
and I first saw it we were more making
fun of it than actually getting sucked
into the story but again being kids we
did put it on once or twice after we
kind of accepted what it was just a
cheap knockoff rushed out really fast
and I guess achieve knockoffs go it's
not the worst it's just not very good
its purpose is made totally complete by
the ending where it just seems to end
really abruptly they just say hey we
want to go see the world and it just
kind of stops I remember we were
scratching our heads what that was about
and then a few days later the Aladdin
cartoon show came out so yeah really all
this was was a pilot episode for the
Aladdin cartoon honestly I probably
would have liked it more if it just came
forward and said that's what this was if
they just announced there was an Aladdin
show coming out and this was going to be
the first episode or a couple of
episodes tied together like what they
usually do with the Disney Afternoon but
no they had to put it on VHS slap return
of Jafar on it and thus we now have to
judge it as a Disney movie not at the at
record release but still a sequel to a
theatrical release and in that case it's
pretty bad what would have made a
passable TV pilot is now the beginning
of a long line of disappointing DVD
sequels the only part that kind of gets
a chuckle every once in a while is Jason
Alexander is the thief but that's
because it's Jason Alexander and
anything he touches his hilarious well
almost Disney did manage to crush him
but even when he's saying unfunny lines
he can get a little bit of a laugh out
of him he's just that good as for the
rest I think the word to describe it is
probably awkward it's not god-awful it's
not like there was no effort put into it
it's just awkward looking back years
later it's not that big a deal
especially we know all the sequels Erica
come out after but for a bunch of kids
that were excited to finally see a
sequel to one of the biggest Disney
films they've ever seen
it was pretty underwhelming I know it
has a soft spot for some I was just
never one to get into it but this would
only be the beginning of the Disney
sequels suckfest war we're on the way
and there was so much more suffering to
be had
[Music]
well with the return too far doing so
well in sales and the animated series
being a pretty modest hit it only made
sense to wrap it all up with one more
Aladdin movie Aladdin and the King of
Thieves a much better sequel than the
last one not only is it more cinematic
in both the story and its visual style
but it actually puts the focus back on
Aladdin and the troubles he's going
through doesn't make it good I don't
know if I can go that far there are
still a lot of things that don't work
about it but I can at least say I was
genuinely entertained and even kind of
impressed aladdin and Jasmine are
finally getting married yeah I guess
they push that whole three days thing
off a bit but like he said he's the
Sultan that can change the laws so why
even have a law that she has to be
married ah who knows fairy tales haha
but Aladdin is feeling sad because he
can't invite his father to the wedding
because well he never knew his father
but that all changes Wade discovers his
father is actually the king of the forty
thieves and tries to rob the wedding
he's trying to get this scepter that's
in the palace that contains an Oracle
that can tell him where the greatest
treasure of all is the hand of Midas Oh
Adhan and his father played by John
rhys-davies finally meet up and don't
know what to really make of each other
the father is confused about how he made
it to a place of royalty and a lab is
confused why his father is still a thief
both want a relationship to bloom but
both have issues trusting the other
especially a lab entrusting his father
and we find out the rightfully so the
father still wants to find the hand of
Midas and will do anything to achieve it
so Aladdin puts off his wedding and goes
back and forth trying to figure out
whether or not he wants to help his
father and get the treasure or if he
just wants his father back to be well
his father and yeah this is kind of the
main problem with the film I give them
credit for tackling the issue of
father's that aren't very good fathers
as it can be a very tough issue
sometimes can turn over a new leaf but
other times are still caught in this
selfish cycle but here's the problem
Aladdin's father cycle doesn't really
make sense
he says they left Aladdin because he
couldn't provide for him and his wife so
he goes and joins the 40 thieves to get
his treasure so that well he can support
them they clearly fight a lot fetchers
but he never comes back well okay maybe
they are building him up is kind of a
deadbeat dad but no they tried to give
him these sympathetic moe
which I'm usually for except it doesn't
match at all what he was talking about
anyone that talks like how this father
talks about his son wouldn't do the
things that he does he would be happy to
go to the wedding he wouldn't give a
crap about the treasure in fact there's
really no point to care about the
treasure he can just go and live in the
palace it's all just a pride thing but
then at the end he throws away the
treasure even though he tried so hard to
get it but wait Aladdin was helping him
find the treasure - why does Aladdin
suddenly care about this it's so weird
to see a lad and just abandon his
wedding and then be like hey let's go
find this treasure that really I don't
care about but he doesn't really
cheerfully and the father is all okay
with it and it just doesn't add up the
motivations constantly go back and forth
but not in a way I feel was intentional
if you want to see his kind of story
done so much better watch Adventure Time
and Finn's connection to his father or
even strangely enough Fresh Prince of
bel-air and his connection with his real
father these shows get it and they know
how to explain it well I don't think
this one really does it feels more like
they want to do something with a lab in
connecting to his father but they also
want a treasure hunt so they just kind
of smash them together and yeah given
the probable short amount of time that
they had on this I guess I can't be
surprised what we got but that still
doesn't mean that the heart and focus
works and when the heart and focus
doesn't work the film really suffers and
it's hard to get behind it but that's
not the only problem the first Aladdin
was very good at balancing out the
characters everybody felt like they got
the appropriate amount of screen time in
this one it's mostly on Aladdin which is
better than return to fire whereas
mostly on Iago but all Jasmine does is
show some support and then mostly stays
out of the picture and all the genie
does is want to plan a wedding speaking
of which let's talk about the genie
because Robin Williams is back to voice
him and that's both kind of a pro and a
con it's a pro because it's Robin
Williams as improvising is incredible
but it's a con because unlike the first
film they don't always know when to cut
him off granted in the original they do
leave the camera on him too long
sometimes but they knew to keep the
focus on Aladdin and the story and so
forth in this one I actually kind of
dreaded whenever the genie was gonna
come on screen even when he made me
laugh it
just didn't connect to anything it's
like he comes in and just hijacks the
movie when we could be spending more
time trying to get the motivations of
Aladdin and his father down or give
Jasmine more time or make the villain
more interesting just everytime he shows
up even when it's hilarious
it still feels out of place at first I
thought the songs were gonna be really
good the first one really had me tapping
my feet and kind of humming it
afterwards but then outside of a do way
from Aladdin and jasmine they all sound
exactly like that I swear it's like the
exact same song in the exact same rhythm
just a few notes are missing or changed
there's very little variety which is
ironic because I know more than one
songwriter worked on this but for all
its problems like I said there are a lot
of good things blames jokes though they
do go on too long
aren't still mostly funny I think to at
least try to tie in some of the
characters at the end jasmine throws a
punch and the genie gets a few action
scenes and like I said you can tell
they're trying to go that extra mile
look at some of this animation this is
the same crew that brought the Aladdin
TV show to life TV shows back then
didn't have a big animation budget so
for them to come together and pull off
something that looks this good it's
really impressive the angles the
movement the lighting the colors you can
tell they knew this was gonna be the
last thing Aladdin related and they
wanted to try their hardest to make it
good
and give them credit for all the action
and singing there are a lot of times
where people just sit down and talk when
it's actually needed and welcomed and
those scenes don't feel forced they flow
very naturally it's just once again the
motivations there's a difference between
being intentionally complex and sloppily
complex
I feel like this movie had a lot of
really good scenes and ideas but no
concentrated narrative to have them
connect or flow so it's a tough call I
don't see it really working as a film
but I'm also kind of happy I saw it it
was visually interesting it was creative
you could tell it was trying to have a
real heart and soul and I give a credit
that was trying to wrap up both the TV
series and the movies it even ends with
the merchants singing the song at the
end those are kind of nice bookends I
get a feeling if I was a little kid I'd
be into it and as an adult there's some
neat stuff it's just that now that ever
really
but you gotta give prop to the directors
and animators who you know we're on a
tough deadline for this for Disney
sequels and shows they're almost never
given enough time to be fleshed out this
was a valiant attempt to justly wrap up
another Arabian night
[Music]
let's get this over with Bell's magical
world I can safely say that this is the
first Disney sequel I've seen during
this Disney cember that is clearly just
doing the bare minimum help I even know
if it's doing that I guess with the
popularity of Beauty and the Beast
enchanted Christmas they felt well why
not do another one just something
anything
I don't know throw it out there and
that's what this movie feels like they
just took something anything and vomited
it up before us what's the story there
isn't one
well no there there's like four or five
it's not even really a movie it doesn't
really begin it doesn't really end it
starts off in a lame-ass CG library he
gives us the set up again how Belle
traveled to a castle and comes across
all these little characters and the
beasts and then it's just a few stories
about when she was there there's a part
where she's angry at the beasts and they
fight over who's gonna apologize first
that ends then there's a part about
Lumiere being in love with the feather
duster that ends there's one where mrs.
Potts feels left out that ends and
there's one with a bird with a broken
wing that ends and then it all ends that
was it it doesn't even wrap up the
opening at least had a narrator saying
hey this is going on the ending just it
just stops
it's pointless it's stupid there is no
reason for it to exist is that a movie
is that what counts as a movie talk
about false advertising look at the
cover
it shows Belle in the yellow dress the
famous yellow dress it doesn't even
appear in this what does appear really
sucks
well the animation in enchanted
Christmas wasn't phenomenal it's still
pretty good again you could tell they
were trying they just didn't have the
budget to do as well as the first one
but they were really trying to make it
look like the first one well it looks
like they took the budget enchanted
Christmas and cut that in half again
look at everybody they look awful this
doesn't look like a beauty in the beasts
movie it looks like Beauty and the Beast
the TV show like what they do with a
Ladd and the TV show was that the idea
was this going to be a Beauty and the
Beast TV show and then they just
scrapped at the last minute but they
figure it we have four or five of these
already done just slap a movie title on
it and say Belle's magical world what's
even magical about it we seen all this
before there's nothing new it's just
don't worry used to this there's nothing
even that match
all about it what is that weird face has
now become a meme magical okay it is a
little magical but everything else is
totally pointless if you're just gonna
lazily throw these things together and
expect it to be a movie expect it to be
judged as a movie this is clearly just
something for three or four year-olds I
know what you're thinking oh is that
like with the original Beauty and the
Beast was no it was nominated for Best
Film not this anime film that didn't
even exist yet maybe it's because of
this movie that that category exists
come on it's Disney is there anything
good in it well I like this line one
thing to do we must scream like
bloodless cowards this one's kind of
cute I guess the cartoony animation
isn't that bad but the animation went
supposed to look serious like a bell of
a beast is just pathetic
so yeah two lines from Lumiere some
cartoony stuff that because of the low
bar I have to congratulate them on
looking cartoony but aside from that no
he's really nothing if you have a
toddler that likes anything show this
because they'll like anything else
magical world it sucks and on to the
next one bye
[Music]
yeah because out of all the Disney
properties that people seem to love the
most
it was Pocahontas clearly we needed a
sequel to that truth be told I don't
know what's more shocking the fact that
they actually made a sequel to this film
that was so historically inaccurate and
the majority of audiences didn't like
and even many said was the beginning of
the downfall of hand-drawn Disney
animation or the fact that I can't
believe I'm saying this I actually
enjoyed this one a little bit more than
the original but if you know what I
think of the original that's not saying
much it's still not good in fact there
are seen start downright cringe-worthy
to sit through but again as I'm finding
out with some of these Disney sequels
there was a legitimate talent going in
that I have to admire on some levels
sort of the film opens up as stupid as
you think a movie called Pocahontas too
would open up John Smith is apparently
killed by the villain from the last film
Ratcliffe somehow through some very
confusing exposition especially for a
kid's film this means that the white man
can go and invade Pocahontas his tribe
but one man named John Rolfe played by
Billy Zane believes this is unfair so he
pleads with the king to talk to the
chief and see if they can work out
something between the two the chief is
resistant though especially seeing how
the settlers on their land are not
always the best haha just wait until
what happens in the future but
Pocahontas his daughter offers to go in
his place Rolfe begrudgingly agrees but
thinks there's still some way to turn
this into something positive even if
he's not getting the chief himself
Pocahontas is thus introduced to a new
world and finds out that she's gonna
make any progress she has to adapt
thus she learns their etiquette their
way of doing things and of course puts
on a pretty dress that they can mark it
to all the Disney princess lines let's
see where is it there she is it's
borderline of my fair lady's story but
keeps just interesting enough that
doesn't become too clichd and she does
a good job winning the people over
showing that they're not all just
savages and that they can in fact be
very intelligent and very peaceful but
when Ratcliffe brings in a bear to
torture as apparently this was some sort
of entertainment in the day I'm not sure
if that's true but if we allowed
bullfighting guess anything's possible
Pocahontas stands up for the poor
creature thus driving the King insane
for some reason orders her to be thrown
in jail and the attack on her people to
begin
and we go right back into stupid
territory again with swordfights John
Smith returning a romance blooming even
though apparently the person she fell in
love with before doesn't count anymore
even though he was kind of still
interested but not but it's okay because
her is the capable strong hero is
suddenly seen doing very little in terms
of saving the day all of a sudden it
gets so stupid there's an immense
tragedy with this film because unlike
the first one I didn't always know where
it was going and the way was written and
the way was animated and the way it was
paced it was surprisingly kind of
engaging with the first film I knew
every second every line every character
what was going to happen it was so
predictable you knew the exact message
plot when things were gonna happen it
was just ridiculous the only thing you
really had going for it was a good color
scheme and some nice music here the
color scheme and music aren't quite as
good obviously with the budget cut but
there is still a lot of artistic merit
not only some of the scenery really nice
and by god I forgot what a good singer
the voice actress of Pocahontas is but I
felt the expressions in this were much
stronger than the last one in fact a lot
of scenes of pointless dialogue are
taken out just replaced by how they look
look at this scene where Pocahontas
saying goodbye to her best friend they
barely say a thing but look at that look
at the emotion in their faces
it's remarkable there's another great
scene where she first sees the king and
she freezes they never explain why they
never talk about it but you just feel
the moment and it's a quiet scene
there's not a lot of in-your-face music
it can actually be very subtle there's a
real conflict between how much of
Pocahontas culture does she give up to a
debt and how much does she hold on to
what does she sacrifice for the greater
good that's ten times more interesting
than what we got in the last film where
you knew from begin to end what was
gonna happen I really hated how at the
end of the last film she didn't go to
the New World she just stayed with her
people and I thought why why are you
closing those possibilities why are you
just keeping things separate but in this
one you do see the lands explored you
see how she reacts to things and it's
interesting and it's charming and the
romance is nice and this whole side
character that's following her around
trying to protect her he's cool I like
how all the people don't know how to
accept her but they don't immediately
they're just curious they're unsure and
I don't know it just felt more relatable
it felt more interesting which is both
surprising but also a shame that it
started off so terrible and it ends so
terrible
I've never seen a movie where the middle
was the best part again for what these
people had to make and what could have
so easily been a phoned-in project I
really felt they were trying it just
didn't work whether it be because of
notes from Disney or they just made the
wrong choices or they didn't think the
thing all the way through but yeah to
its credit there were much more moments
where I was sucked in with Pocahontas
too than I was with the first one so I
guess if you're really interested in
checking out I would probably say just
fast-forward to where she's going to the
new world and then stop at where they're
torturing the bear because anything
outside of that is garbage but for some
strange reason the middle part of this
movie is actually pretty strong okay
it's not perfect but it's Pocahontas too
I was thoroughly impressed I got
anything interesting at all so I guess
I'm glad some parts of it worked hell
actually a good chunk of it worked but
it still doesn't work as a complete
whole and that does really damage it the
bad scenes aren't just bad they're
embarrassingly bad if you're curious
it's not creatively bankrupt
I actually am glad I saw this movie or
at least the middle anyway but the rest
of the colors of the wind sadly are
blowing me away
[Music]
I start telling people I was doing the
direct-to-dvd sequels a lot of people
were saying that Lion King 2 actually
was okay and yeah I see what they're
talking about it's probably the best way
to describe okay is it the first film
no but it's a bells magical world no
it's not good it's not bad it's not
incredible but it's not awful either
it's a perfect middle-of-the-road film
that you would probably expect Simba and
Nala have given birth to a bouncing baby
girl named Kiara voiced by Jeff Campbell
simply shows her the ropes just like his
father did but it turns out there's a
dark shadowy place that they need to
stay away from no not the hyenas now
it's the outsiders a group of lions that
like the leadership a scar and vowed to
get the land back their leader named
Zira is training a lion cub named Kovu
to be a cold-blooded killer who grows up
kill Simba and ultimately takes control
why him well apparently he's a not
descendant from scar yeah it's a little
confusing he's not his son but scar took
him in as his own even though there was
never anything the last movie that show
they did it's pretty forced and stupid
but don't know it makes the message in
the end so much stronger Kiara
of course befriends Kovu but they're
told that they're gonna grow up to be
natural enemies a few years pass and
seemingly it looks like Kovu wants to
leave his pack having saved Kira's life
and using that as leverage to join Simba
what they don't know is that Kovu is
actually planning to kill Simba when he
has the chance but you know it the two
just happened to get along and of course
fall in love and that makes things
really complicated will love prevail and
the two warring sides see their faults
is this as clear a metaphor for Romeo
and Juliet as the first one was for
Hamlet personally I think it's clever
that they're taking from Shakespeare's
second biggest play after his first
biggest play apart from a few other
things but that's in our story the old
characters like Simba Timon Pumbaa and
Zazu all feel kind of recycled even with
the original voice actors coming back
but the new characters and their voice
actors seem to breathe this very
likeable life into them I really like
the people they got to play the new
parts were the original actors well not
all bad just kind of feel like they're
doing their usual shtick
Rafiki has a song that doesn't really
add much
simba has a cold dream sequence but
outside of that he's just kind of the
mean father
now let's practically pointless Timon
and Pumbaa well I'd even like that much
in the first film so now on the sequel
we get the table scraps of that comedy
but everyone else really seems to care
about this story even if it doesn't
always make sense it's almost cruel to
compare the animation of this one to the
original as the original was one of the
big as anime and movies ever made it's
just huge it's one of the few films
where they rerelease it I go to see it
on the big screen every time now we have
that animation budget cut in half and
what do you expect it's direct-to-video
as director video goes it's bit they
still have some of that nice line work
and try to work in some good backgrounds
but yeah you're always gonna be
comparing it to how good the first one
looked and that's always gonna be a
little distracting but honestly for what
it is it's pretty decent the songs I
surprisingly kind of like I even found
myself humming some of them after the
movie was done we are one is a nice
melody in to bending while pointless is
still a nice rhythm and even the song he
lives in you I think that's in the
Broadway version isn't it so you know
that's got to be pretty solid in many
respects the film doesn't need to exist
the first Lion King truly was a
spectacle to look at and when you do it
direct-to-dvd movie that's trying to
capture something similar you know
you're not gonna get it so it almost
seems pointless but if I was forced to
make a direct-to-video sequel on the
Lion King this is probably what I would
turn into there is a lot of effort in
what I'm sure is not a lot of time and
not a lot of money at least by Disney
Feature Film standards he's it awkward
at times yeah but it does have enough
character to it that even though I felt
like I knew what was gonna happen I
still wanted to see it happen if it was
a feature film I'd probably be a little
harder on it but since it's a
direct-to-video movie I think it's okay
it gave me exactly what I expected and
nothing really more but I wasn't
expecting more if anything I was
expecting less if you want to see
something on par with the first Lion
King you're definitely not gonna get
that here but honestly I don't know
anyone do the things they're gonna get
that if you want to see sort of a TV
sequel with better than TV animation I
think this one's fine kind of a
middle-of-the-road review but it's kind
of a middle-of-the-road movie pop it in
and judge for yourself
[Music]
well after a film as 90s as a goofy
movie we can go even more nineties
easier with an extremely goofy movie yep
because everything in the 90s was hmm a
chance surprised I didn't spell this
with an X because well we'll get to that
in a minute I guess in a sense this is
exactly what I think of when I hear
direct-to-dvd sequels or at least what I
thought they were gonna be before they
started doing the big popular movies
goofy movie was a modest success and it
did pretty well on VHS so it kind of
figure to do a direct-to-dvd movie
that's just kind of what they did back
then and honestly you get what you'd
expect a movie like this would offer it
opens with Max and his friends getting
ready to go off to college
goofy once again is having a hard time
as a loving parent letting go of his kid
its credit well is cramming a lot of the
cool stuff at the time in your face it
does take some time to actually be a
little emotionally considerate but
things go south when goofy is fired from
his job and has to find another one he's
told that the majority of jobs require
college degrees nowadays so enter
exactly what you think is gonna happen
goofy goes to college with max and under
pretty much every other thing you think
is gonna happen max enters a competitive
sport there's a bully that makes fun of
him they're prepping cheaters who make
fun of the fact that his father is there
who of course makes things worse
Max is embarrassed that relationship is
pulled apart again and of course it ends
with some sort of big sports event oh
did I say some sort of event like I
forgot what it was no no I remember you
could forget for the life of you it's
the X Games because they pound it the
hell into you
it's beyond obvious that Disney owns
ESPN because they plaster that
everywhere to Max's whole goal in this
thing is to enter the X Games and win it
it's so weird to see that logo without
some sort of parody or satire in there
but no it's all just one obvious
commercial it's really weird so okay the
stories about recycled as it can get is
there anything good in it
yeah there's a couple things like I said
there's one or two emotional moments
that are brief but effective I feel like
the animation is trying to be funnier
than it's allowed like the bully
character he's an amazing actor but he's
just not given a dialogue or scenes
very funny but at the same time look at
him you kind of want to laugh at him a
little bit goofy also starts a bit of a
romance with this librarian who's also
low-key and awkward and again look at
how she's animated you do kind of wild
laugh at her but the key word is want as
in they want you to laugh they want to
get reaction out of you but there's just
not that much substance there some
things I don't even get like max and the
bullies are in this beatnik coffeehouse
which did those even exist anymore I
mean no there's coffee houses but come
on these people look like they're out of
50s not the 90s and they all start
snapping that for some reason scares the
bullies away I don't get it this whole
movie feels like a really good joke
being set up but for whatever reason we
never quite get the punchline that kind
of holds back it never becomes anything
it just sort of falls into that mesh of
typical College movies except now for
kids hell did this inspire monsters you
know I'm so thankful for that I don't
think these are as entertaining as
Disney thinks they are it just kind of
feels like opportunities they're never
fully taken advantage of and speaking of
which I'm just gonna say it I miss
Roxanne I mean I know high school going
to different colleges puppy love
separates you all that stuff but I'm
sorry they were a really cute couple
could the movie have been about that
maybe about them breaking up or deciding
whether or not they wanted to stay
together or going to different schools
you know actual interesting stuff stuff
that some kids may need to know when
going to college but nope it's all about
being the sports star and trying not to
be embarrassed by your wacky parents I'd
see this only if you're a die-hard goof
troop fan or I don't know an example of
them will be trying to save itself
despite a bad script but now that
interests you it's exactly what you
think of directed DVD movies gonna be
take it for what's worth and see the X
Games yourself die me an extremely goofy
movie yourself cast a battalion
[Music]
so I'm not gonna lie one of the few
Disney sequels that piqued my interest a
little bit was Little Mermaid to us I
have returned you far I never saw any of
the Disney sequels they just didn't
piqued my interest and I think I was a
little too old for them but when I saw
the commercials for this one about
Ariel's daughter who is a human who
wants to become a mermaid I thought yeah
okay I wasn't expecting much I know it's
a Disney sequel but I thought there were
some possibilities in this I popped it
in gave it a watch and yeah it sucked
okay maybe that's too strong a word but
it just felt like an hour and a half of
nothing this story should be so easy to
make interesting but instead you just
felt like they're going through the
motions the motions that we got see
these characters again we got to at
least five dumb kids movies cliches that
you've seen everywhere and we have to in
no way make the characters feel like
their decisions are making the story
flow doing what the story says they have
to do that's a shame because like I said
I thought this was a good idea
Aereo and Erik have given birth to a
little girl named melody she's about to
be introduced to her grandfather Triton
but then Ursula's crazy sister
interrupts and threatens to kill melody
unless Triton hands over his magic
trident she's defeated but they decide
to follow frozen parents logic and just
keep her away from the thing that she
would obviously be very drawn to instead
of finding about a million other ways
around this so she can never be told
about merpeople or the sea or anything
like that in fact they even build a wall
in between the kingdoms insert some joke
here but Triton tell Sebastian to keep
an eye on her because yeah that makes
sense and twelve years pass but
everybody acts like it was just 12
minutes no really 12 years later
Sebastian is like oh look after her he
said but wait why do I feel like he just
said that was 12 years ago
also Ursula sister is trying to turn
this little guppy back into a shark that
was just transformed into a guppy why
are you still doing this 12 years later
and acting like it just happened a few
minutes ago this is the kind of logic
this movie runs on melody constantly
sneaks under the wall and goes into the
sea because she loves it so much
she doesn't question that she can talk
to crabs and fish and seagulls but
apparently everyone else does and sees
her as kind of weird when Sebastian
accidentally gets loose during a party
and causes a big scene
she thinks she's to blame even though
nobody says she's to blame and this
ruins her big night that I guess could
have possibly gone awkward anyway you
see Ariel cross her fingers though we
don't know why she's afraid to dance
with this boy though we don't know why
she looks down at her feet like she
doesn't know how to dance but this was
never addressed yeah we're not even at
the meat of the story yet and nothing is
adding up she finds her own magical
locket that shows that the underwater
city is real and this convinces her that
it's totally rational to leave her home
and try to find it yeah again kind of
crazy she comes across Ursula sister who
turns her into a mermaid but sadly says
she doesn't have enough magic to keep
her that way the only thing that does
have enough magic is King Triton's
Trident who she now says he stole from
her because melody has succumbed to
stupidly written kit syndrome like it
all bad scripts she believes her thanks
Trident is the bad guy and goes and
tries to steal from him along the way
she comes across see Timon and Pumbaa
yeah I'm sure they have other names but
it's just Timon and Pumbaa underwater
and she even totally 100% betrays her
mother while also simultaneously dooming
the world a whole god is this movie
stupid every second there's another dumb
thing that doesn't add up or something
that just makes a character look selfish
or idiotic when melody finds out that
her mother has been lying to her and
that her life is a lie
look at us she runs right past her dad
the dad doesn't even give a shit oh hey
Ariel
what's up why tend to your daughter you
idiot he doesn't even go with Ariel to
go find her he just stays behind and
says good luck even jasmine threw a
punch in aladdin 3 this guy just does
nothing the only character is very
occasionally of interest are either
melody or the evil sister once in a
while they do a good expression on them
and hey pet Carol's back to do the voice
you can read the phone book and make it
sound deliciously evil even the
animation is just generic I can't say
it's bad but nothing really stands out
about it either
I remember the incredible expressions
that they gave Ariel in the first one
even once you couldn't talk the
animation on her face was just so
passion
and so well done here she just feels
like a robot look kind of happy look
kind of sad look kind of worried look
kind of whimsical
it's like talking the notes instead of
singing the notes the Disney sequels
that had generic animation always had
something that stood out about it
Pocahontas too had a lot of great
expressions and some good nature shots
Beauty and the Beast too has some nice
winter colors and that awesome organ
this just seems like it's there to do
its job and that's it I can't totally
blame them I'm sure they were rushed and
had to get it out fast but it's just so
weird that nothing freaking nothing
stands out about it even the songs are
forgettable I don't remember a single
one I don't know I guess I shouldn't be
shocked I mean it's a Disney sequel this
is what we're supposed to expect but I
really like this idea I wanted to see
more of melody longing for the sea I
wanted to see more conflict between her
and the parents I wanted her when she
finally gets into the ocean to see what
a spectacular world it is like her life
is starting anew but instead of feeling
any of that you just kind of shown it
you're told what's going on and not
experiencing it I guess it's not awful
especially compared to other Disney
sequels it's just bland and not very
memorable and for an idea like this
especially being a sequel to such a
passionate film you would think even a
rushed sequel off of something so
passionate with least some kind of
impact I guess it's fine and corny
enough for little kids but for someone
who really loved the Beauty energy and
elegance of the original for me
this definitely flounders
[Music]
of all the Disney sequels I've reviewed
so far lady in the Tramp too seems to be
the closest in spirit to the original
now that's not saying a ton seeing how I
thought the original was only okay but
to be fair I think it was meant to be
kind of a smaller movie anyway as soon
as its sequel starts you'd swear you
were in the exact same film the
animation is really top-notch and looks
eerily similar to the original I don't
know why they throw all their effort
into these lady in the tram films I mean
they're just dogs walking around why
would you make them look this good
but they do man it's beautiful to look
at the story itself ranges from generic
to actually kind of okay but again for a
lady in the Tramp it's not like I'm
expecting anything spectacular here the
film takes place not even a year after
the original Lady and the Tramp still
have puppies and they seem to be a happy
family but one of them seems to get into
a lot of trouble that being skinned
voice distractingly so by Scott wolf
yeah look at this thing you expect a
cute little kid voice to come out of it
something high-pitched but instead what
do we get but I want to run wild and
free like a real dog God does that not
fit I go wherever I want do whatever I
please you know the only reason they
went with this voice is so they could
get a semi celebrity in there and it
just doesn't work but thankfully the
rest of the voice actors aren't that bad
as he wants to run away from home and
join a bunch of junkyard dogs one of
them named angel played by Alyssa Milano
takes him under her wing and shows him
the ways of the outdoors but things get
tricky when scamp doesn't know where he
belongs in the home life or the outdoor
life it gets even trickier when it looks
like Angel wants a home life and even
had a home life buzz had her heart
broken many times before and even
trickier when the leader of the junkyard
dogs has it in for his father yeah it
sounds like a semi reversal the first
film and not really too interesting but
actually they do quite a bit with it the
pacing in this film is a lot slower than
other Disney sequels and it's very
welcomed much like the original there's
this real elegance and color to it the
backgrounds are just glowing and when a
character goes through something they
don't just say a line and then run away
they actually kind of sit there and let
the moment sink in the songs are
actually rather fitting - okay there's
an occasional lame lyric here and there
but the style matches the
time period perfectly there's even a
ragtime in it and for these types of
songs they're actually done pretty well
does it all work no there's definitely
the cliches that you can see coming and
certainly a groaner line here are there
and I really didn't get what age
everybody was supposed to be I mean okay
scamp is supposed to be a puppy but they
get an adult voicing it well okay maybe
he's still a little kid but Alyssa
Milano voices the other maybe puppy they
don't really make it clear she's a puppy
maybe she's just a small dog but there's
clearly a romance blooming between them
so okay maybe she is a puppy but then
she talks about how she's been in and
out of five families five families you
can't be that young and go through five
families but okay give the bad for the
doubt maybe she has me she is still a
puppy the leader of the junkyard dogs
clearly an adult has the hots for her
always calling her his girl how does
this work so yeah little scenes like
that and kind of a phone in climax make
it lame at some points but truth be told
I was actually kind of impressed with
how much it felt like the original Lady
and the Tramp they do try to make you
feel something they do show the dilemmas
the characters are going through they do
take the time for it I can't really see
it's great because I don't think the
first film or this one we're meant to be
really great they're supposed to be
small elegant pleasant little movies and
okay there's definitely problems that
hold me back from liking it as much as
the first one I mean the first one did
have a little bit more of an edge to it
but I think if you're someone that
actually wanted to see a sequel to Lady
and the Tramp
this'll do you find if this is a story
you for some reason really want to see
continue I say check it out it might be
an adequate spin-off to dig your
positive
[Music]
yeah Cinderella - dreams come true and
if you think that title is unbelievably
boring and generic well you just summed
up this entire sequel why do people
think there needs to be more than
happily ever after that's a perfectly
good ending it's the most popular ending
of all time but no this thrilling fairy
tale needs to continue with the fairy
godmother now living in the palace for
some reason I guess she wasn't happy
just living as a pile of sparkling dust
however that works but instead she likes
to read to her mice friends but oh no
they won't do something nice for
cinderelly this is the major concern of
the film so she recommends that they
make a book with all the fascinating
stories that happened in the castle
that's right all three of them because
that's all that's we're telling in an
hour and a half and honestly I don't
even know of those are really worth
telling yep it's another one of those
anthology stories where they just throw
three separate stories together don't
really connect them that well and well
everybody suffers for it the first story
is about Cinderella learning how to be a
princess she has to learn how to dance
ride and dress right and turn away
commoners and cook boring food it's hard
but it's okay some R&B pop songs help
her out
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo so this is love all
these classic songs hell with that shit
that nobody will ever remember now we
have pop songs sung by pop singers whose
nobodies names they remember even if
they sneeze it by accident you want a
real good laugh fast-forward to the
credits and hear their R&B version of
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo I'm not even kidding
it's pretty hilarious but that's just
one of the three boring-ass stories jack
is apparently tired of being a mouse so
the fairy godmother turns him into a
human but being a human is really hard
and you can guess where as bullshit goes
from there
the last story is about a stepsister
Anastasia wanting to get a day for the
ball the fact that any of them would go
to the ball after everything that's
happened is kind of funny but what's
even funnier that Cinderella is totally
okay with helping her out yeah all this
sabotaging like you're in a room all
forgiven Cinderella just wants her to
discover how to be her true self the
truth
is hard the sequel in so many ways
reminds me a bells magical journey right
down to all the stories that they tried
to tell and don't really tie them
together is it quite as bad as that one
I guess not I mean the animation is ten
times better than deserves to be then
give it some credit they tried to tie it
together even if it was really loosely
and they kept the stories really short
just down to three but big shock you
know that these stories are really
interesting and definitely not worthy of
the title Cinderella - at least Beauty
and the Beast in call it Beauty and the
Beast 3 this is marketed as a direct
sequel and it's obviously not it's just
some stories they threw together but
come on haven't you ever want to hear
Cinderella say this hair ooh this hair
yes and haven't you ever wanted to see
Lucifer wear Rastafarian hat oh my god
what oh it's so stupid the only thing
that's kind of likable in this whole
thing again aside from the animation is
surprisingly Anastasia is kind of a
likable character I know I made fun of
the fact that Cinderella helps her out
and yet technically in the story it
doesn't really make sense but the way
they animate her and the way the voice
acting is done I do genuinely kind of
feel sorry for her it's the one thing I
didn't really expect I guess it's
actually done kind of okay oh no I feel
they did a surprising if not sporadic
job of suddenly making her kind of
likable but what does it matter they
still put her in the same bullshit
stories with the same misunderstandings
that suddenly make everybody turn away
and go oh no he doesn't love me all that
bullshit this movie's stupid this
movie's pointless this movies dumb I
enjoy the animation but that kind of
makes me hated even more the same nature
could gone to something so much better I
feel like it's just wasted everything is
wasted except the opportunity because
there is no opportunity so he can't even
call it a wasted opportunity I guess if
you have like a little little kid and
they just want to see Cinderella and a
palace try on dresses spin around all
that nonsense it's fine I mean there's
nothing really ethically wrong form or
anything but if you want show them a
fairy tale that's gonna enchant and
delight this shoe is definitely on the
friggin for it you know
[Music]
ah this hurts Hunchback of Notre 'adam -
of all the films that shouldn't have a
sequel this is one of them and of all
the films that people were telling me to
beware of the most when doing these
sequels it was Hunchback of Notre Dom -
the sad thing about though is even
though it is terrible it's terrible for
different reasons than I thought it was
gonna be terrible I mean don't get me
wrong the story is shit a circus comes
into town and an evildoer wants to steal
this super ritzy Belle that just happens
to be in no trade ah it looks like any
ordinary Belle but on the inside it's
gorgeous and beautiful and full of
treasures get it get it
one of the circus performers his name
Medellin played by jennifer Love Hewitt
she's working with the evil villain
played by Michael McKean to be
romantically interested with Quasimodo
to lure him away from the bells so he
can steal it of course a real-life
romance blooms between them but why
revealed it stolen before she can
confess what's really going on and of
course she has a tragic backstory that
doesn't really make sense she was a
thief and he's the only one that could
look after her yet really she could move
anywhere and nobody would know about
there's a million other ways around this
but if that seems too heavy and
traumatic for you it's okay Haley Joel
Osment placed the child of Phoebus and
Esmeralda and this introduces us to one
of the biggest problems of the movie
taking mostly Academy Award nominated
actors and just having him say stupid
shit it's so hard seeing so many great
actors just given a generic bullshit
script to work with and that really is
the biggest problem the script is awful
from the initial set up you know
everything that's gonna happen what
every character is gonna do when they're
gonna do it it's just ridiculous and why
do we need an appearances can be
deceiving story when the first one was
already in appearances can be deceiving
story but let's get to the toughest
thing to talk about for me and that's
the animation this was done by TMS the
people behind Acura Batman the Animated
Series and a maniac some of the greatest
animation I've ever seen top 5 of all
time in my
but I'm not gonna lie they just don't
seem like the right choice here not that
they can't emulate the Disney style I
mean they look like the characters fine
it's just that this looks more like a
Disney Afternoon movie and what I mean
by that is TMS doesn't traditionally use
a lot of CGI Disney does TMS doesn't
usually use colored lines Disney does
TMS is big strength is not in heartfelt
emotion but more aggressive emotion
Akira is aggressive batman is aggressive
Disney can be aggressive but it's no
more for the sentimental side for
example when a character needs to be
still TMS has them almost completely
still every once in a while maybe a
little movement with Disney they're
always somehow moving they have like a
million in-betweener so when you're
holding on a face it still looks like
there's some movement there TMS doesn't
function that way it's supposed to be a
little rougher so the more tough
emotional scenes they do find like when
Quasimodo finally reveals himself she
steps back she's afraid she runs off
that they did great but scenes were
supposed to feel whimsical and magical
and lovey dovey that's just not their
strong point I keep expecting to see
Wakko Warner come out and bash someone
with a mallet so the animation is still
good it's just not good for this which
is a shame because they do sometimes
make some very bad American projects so
is anything good well Michael McKean as
the villain is actually not that bad I
mean the villain sucks he really sucks
but the voice is legitimately kind of
creepy and I never thought I would get
that out of Michael McKean the music's
nice so not the songs they suck asked
these are some of the dumbest lyrics and
most forgettable melodies I'm talking
about the instrumental score I mean sure
it's not the first hunchback but again
direct-to-dvd you we get it it's gonna
be down a bit but for a direct-to-dvd
musical score it's pretty good and what
do you expect it's Carl Johnson the guy
who did gargoyles that's a great talent
outside of that it's not much it's so
hard to see so many great actors so many
wonderful animators so many phenomenal
talents thrown into just the laziest
dumb a script I don't even know how to
fix it what would you do with Hunchback
of Notre dumb - it just seems like the
first one ended
perfectly I don't know maybe there's a
better writer out there that can make
this work
but for me I'm wishing that gave this
movie the broadway-style ending
[Music]
so what would you like to see a sequel
to Disney's Tarzan one of the biggest
summer hits when it came out or just the
ripples of a cartoon pilot series thrown
together and saying that makes it a
movie well you got the goddamn ladder
give Tarzan and Jane credit that's not
called Tarzan - no no we get that later
it's at least not pretending that this
is supposed to be a flowing cinematic
follow-up but with that said why even
watch it this is another anthology of
stories that aren't really interesting
are usually pointless doesn't have the
same animation doesn't have the same
voice actors they couldn't even give
Phil Collins back they just replay one
of his songs in the opening and then
have a completely different artist at
the end sing about why the stories tied
together
about as well as Cinderella - ties them
Jane is excited because it's the
one-year anniversary of Tarzan marrying
her so she's trying to figure out the
best way to celebrate but every idea she
comes up with seems to have a really
annoying story attached to it the first
story is about her friends coming back
from England trying to save her even
though she doesn't need saving
the second is about some evil guys who
come to the island who trick Tarzan into
trying to show them where some diamonds
are no no diamonds are here the third
story is about yet another asshole who
comes to the island just to make things
hard the moral of the story is anyone
who comes to the island not wearing a
dress is gonna be a dick what makes
these especially funny is that everybody
knows the story that's being told oh I
don't mean the audience though we can
guess everything that's gonna happen -
I'm talking about the characters they
literally know everything that happens
they live through it yet for some reason
they're sitting down and talking about
it some of them don't even end with the
same storyteller one of them starts off
with Jane telling the story and then as
with the elephant finishing it and in
between as you can tell from the
animation this doesn't look especially
cinematic and looks more like a TV
series which it eventually became this
was all just a test to see if kids would
watch Tarzan and Jane in several
different stories well guess what people
don't want to test they want a movie
they want a show pick one and be it I
guess for a TV show the animation isn't
that bad I mean if I saw it on TV I
think it'd be totally acceptable the
quality of the voice for placements
though rarely sound like the original
facts some even sound a little
uncomfortable the only thing more
annoying than Rosie O'Donnell voice is
somebody impersonating Rosie O'Donnell's
voice alright everybody sounds a little
off that is except for a Jane well you
know it's not Minnie Driver whoever does
the voice act Anjali brach I have this
unique energy to it on top of that
Elaine's boss plays one of the villains
now that's just ideal acting sometimes
the friends get a little bit of a laugh
too I don't know I think it's just the
people doing the impersonations they're
a little odd not the worst just kind of
awkward it's may even more awkward by
some of these lines this one woman
clearly has an attraction to Tarzan and
talked about how hot it would be if he
was in a cage cage he's got a cage who's
weird nothing about Tarzan and Jane
feels big authentic or genuine if you
look on the back or watch a preview you
can catch on to that very quickly it is
what it is a quick hash in to see if
they can watch this Disney series it
looks that way it plays that way is it
even worth getting bad angry over it's a
waste of time some kids might enjoy but
I think everybody can agree is entirely
pointless
[Music]
I don't know if it's the string of
particularly bad Disney sequels I had to
sit through the last few days or the
fact that this might actually be a good
movie but 101 dalmatians two patches
London Adventure is actually kind of a
good movie I dare even say on par with
the original yeah I can't believe those
words are leaving my mouth either really
this is the one it has the spirit of the
original artwork similar to the original
some great update some good callbacks
it's exciting I didn't always know where
it was going to go it's funny
adventurous oh my god I think I came
across an actual good Disney sequels it
begins not too shortly after the first
one where we see the Dalmatian
plantation is about to be put into
effect so the family is about to move
but one of the puppies named patch is
feeling a little out of place and it's
understandably so when you're the middle
child of 101 you can get a little lost
hungry for his chance to stand out he
sees that a TV dog named Thunderbolt is
holding auditions for a new dog to be on
his show what he doesn't know is this
current sidekick named little lightning
has told him that they were about to
kill off his character so he needs to
find a way to prove to the public that
he's a real hero patch gets roped in as
he knows everything about the show but
they seem to cause more chaos and misery
than they do save people from it
meanwhile karela oh god how do I even
explain this get sucked into the art
world because she sees a guy who paints
a dot she admits that it feeds her crazy
obsession and they just kind of paint
dots together but he seems to be running
out of inspiration or at least she
doesn't like the work he's putting out
so she once again tries to kidnap the
puppies only this time she's not gonna
make a coat out of him she wants to
paint the canvas with him oh my god that
is delightfully psychotic in fact I
think she's even crazier in this movie
than she was in the last one the flay
thing is as I described this plot I
realize it's kind of a formulaic plot
well for the most part the art stuff is
perfectly out there but there's a lot of
callbacks to the original there's
another liar reveal story another kid
feeling out of place we've seen all this
stuff before in fact this is about as
typical at Disney sequel script as you
can get
but there's one thing this movie has
that those other Disney sequels didn't
have charm it's a charming movie the
characters are so likable the comedy
actually gets a few laughs out loud
laughs the pacing is never too rushed
the slow moments are perfectly slow the
fast moments are perfectly fast the
voice talent is especially good that's
Martin Short as the artist he's really
funny as hell
Karelas voice is hilarious the hero dog
is delightfully full of himself
Jason Alexander is another villain
that's a lot of fun and they got a real
kid to play the puppy not some adult
just doing a high-pitched voice like
this that's just uncomfortable and weird
the artwork is also really great these
are some very distinct backgrounds that
are very similar to the original I like
the original little better because they
were hand painted and these are clearly
computer but by God they still look
great it can be extreme and over-the-top
but it can also be kind of subtle and
delicate too I guess the one thing
that's missing from it is it doesn't
feel quite as big as the original I mean
the climax is another car chase and it's
just Carrillo trying to catch the
puppies again there's even our scene
where all the dogs bark to communicate
but in my opinion the film makes up for
it by having better comedy than the
first the first isn't especially funny
it's just cute this one has a much
better sense of humor and you can tell
the writing is trying much harder than
it really needs to try and I love that I
love taking this idea that really should
only entertain your two-year-old and
actually throwing in some witty dialogue
so is it a great film
by no means but you're talking to a guy
who doesn't even think the first one was
a great film but the first one what's
good thank you dan handsome charm to it
this is exactly the same thing I love
the interaction off of these people I
love that cute little pup talking to the
egotistical dog I like that weird artist
talking to the insane gorilla deville
I like the husband and wife doing a
little counterpoint duet in the opening
it's just it's likable it's really
likable it reminds me a lot of the
Wallace and run this shorts are the
Shaun the Sheep movie it's not like
you're slapping your knee at the comedy
but there's just something inventive
about it something so delightfully
innocent yet still intelligent like I
said I can't act like this is any
phenomenal feed of animation or cinema
story tell
but it's just a nice enjoyable little
movie a movie that couldn't predict
where it was gonna go a movie the head
align or two I might actually quote out
of context a movie I legitimately want
to stay and watch until the very end if
somebody turned it off I would go rent
it and watch the rest of it I know
that's how movies are supposed to work
but for a lot of Disney sequels that's
not what happens it's a perfectly
entertaining little film and after all
the stinkers I've had to watch
entertaining little film to me equals
amazing
[Music]
perhaps the biggest crime of Atlantis
Milo's return is that despite a very
obviously cheap animation budget and oh
I don't know obvious identity as a cheap
cash in which is trained see how the
first end was not a huge box off his
head it's that at first it actually kind
of has an interesting story yeah at
first I was kind of sucked in by it
despite all the bad jokes and awkward
drawn scenes and nary let's look at the
story Milo is still living with Keita in
Atlantis but all his friends returns
saying that apparently some sort of a
Atlantean monster is attacking a bunch
of ships confused by this Keita journeys
to the surface world bringing Milo along
with her and they try to figure out if
this monster is an actual monster or one
of the Atlantean machines or maybe
something else or even someone else they
go on land come across this creepy
village talk to all these semi creepy
people and the more and more they find
out about this mystery the more
questions it seems to raise there's
actually a lot of talking and even kind
of ominous dread and I mean that in the
best way even though it wasn't animated
the best I was actually finding it kind
of interesting but here's the thing when
they do find out what's going on and
what's behind it it seems to raise even
more questions
well that's fine but we never get the
answers there's questions about where
the person who's doing this came from
and how he's able to do what he's doing
is he even doing what he's doing is he
conjoined the monsters the monster
controlling him how can he possess other
people is he possessing other people it
looks like he has to look into their
eyes wait now he doesn't need to look in
their eyes how does this work and just
as it's getting interesting they
completely drop the story yeah they
defeat the bad guy and then they go to a
completely different story now it takes
place in the Wild West and there are
these wind coyotes and I don't know some
guys shit is stolen and they have to get
it back but there's this Native American
who can control the winged coyotes and
it's somehow connects to the ant lanty
and stuff but it doesn't stop there it
then goes to another story where this
crazy guy thinks he's Odin and he steals
the spear that has Atlantean technology
which actually kind of makes him Odin
now and he confuses Keita for his
daughter Brunhilde and shit this is just
another pilot for a TV show isn't it
that explains why the animation looks
this way and why all the stories don't
really connect that well damnit at least
what Tarzan and Jane I knew it was gonna
be a pilot to a TV show of this this
tried harder and fooled me into thinking
it was gonna be something that tries
hard throughout the whole thing I guess
it does technically have an ending and
yeah actually the endings not that bad
it even kind of retcons the ending of
the first film but it's weird when you
see the choice she makes you understand
her reasoning but there's also like a
ton of dangers that happen throughout
this film to go against her reasoning -
I'm not saying what happens is the wrong
choice I'm saying they never explained
the actual dangers that could come along
with it and that's very important to
address so yeah I guess in terms of
other technicals the voice actors are
all replacements and they do a good job
the animation like I said is a huge
budget cut but for kind of TV animation
I guess it's fine sometimes there's a
really inventive idea like there's this
annoying dog that kind of sucks but he
was born in molten lava
so he'll counsel II do things like just
sleep in a fireplace that's not creative
and again when they're actually kind of
talking about this ant lanty and stuff
it is kind of interesting kind of like
the first film in that respect but sadly
it just doesn't stay focused and I don't
even know if it was actually meant to
stay focused this was probably supposed
to be three episodes that were gonna be
connected like I said as a pilot of a TV
show a TV show that never got off the
ground
I mean okay I don't have confirmation of
this but if it wasn't then this really
is the most fragmented direct-to-dvd
sequel ever so I guess it's not awful
it's just not needed and not that
interesting through the majority of it
like I said with the exception of that
first third but even then that's not
great it's just telling an interesting
story that never really has any
conclusion or answers I guess if you
really liked the first Atlantis movie
and you just want to see a little bit
more the technology world and ideas get
hints of it here but if you're looking
for something more this is something
that should definitely stay sunk
[Music]
it's funny when I first saw the movie
lilo and Stitch my initial thought was I
loved everything with the human
characters and thought the alien stuff
was only okay well now with its sequel
stitch I find that strangely enough the
human stuff is only okay but the aliens
are actually a little bit more
entertaining this time does that make
for a good sequel well let's look at the
story lilo and Stitch are enjoying their
time ging used to their new alien family
yeah remember the Russian alien and the
skinny one they're all living together
now but the alien kept on the guard is
furious because he's lost his job and he
wants revenge so he comes across this
sort of strange hamster rabbit thing
with a German accent how do all these
aliens have birth accents anyway and he
sent to get the Russian alien bring him
back and find out where all the other
experiments that he worked on are yeah
remember stitches number 626 so where
are the other 625 well it turns out he's
hidden them and lilo and Stitch come
across a few so it's up to them not only
to discover these other experiments kind
of like finding Pokemon in a sense but
also to save their alien comrade so like
I said before this time it's a little
switched around the aliens in this
actually have some really good laughs
this weird rapid gerbil thing is pretty
funny the captain of the guards is
trying to be serious but keeps having to
come across these annoyances even get
this sidekick voiced by Rob Paulsen even
stitch gets a few more laughs this time
I also really like how the skinny alien
is actually really giving used to
wearing women's clothing and he's
totally okay with it who knows this
might be the first openly transvestite
Disney character unfortunately though
like I said the human characters are not
as good they're not the worst they're
just kind of bland and generic but for
me lilo is one of my favorite kid
characters and to see her just kind of
be like any other Disney generic kid is
really kind of a letdown even Nani who
had to go through so much in the first
film now it just kind of has this side
role I don't know I felt like coming off
the first film where those connections
were so strong and so good this one is
just kind of a background thing maybe
that's why it was called Stitch because
they just wanted to give him more
attention and not as much to the humans
but I like the humans I liked him a lot
I wish more effort was put into him in
this one but let's also be honest this
isn't really meant to be a
fleshed out motion picture I mean look
at the animation it looks like a TV show
and yeah it became a TV show it's a
little difficult to be hard on it when
it's pretty obvious it's just supposed
to be a pilot well as pilots go it got a
few laughs the aliens were needed they
were creative I like the idea of trying
to find more of them in fact I think
that's what the show is about but yeah
it is a letdown that a character as good
as Nani and lilo or just reduce down to
well any generic character you would see
in a Disney sequel but I guess if you're
just looking for a laugh or two and
something relatively harmless it's fine
it's fine for little kids I think that's
who it was aimed at and there's nothing
really insulting in it I mean we lone
Nami are not done well but they're
totally passable for the audience it's
aiming towards it is what it is a cute
little direct-to-dvd pilot for a TV show
and yeah you just can't take what comes
with that I wouldn't watch it again I
don't really think I got much out of it
even watching it the first time but for
what it's trying to do we it does it
okay
get lost in space and see for yourself
[Music]
by god we've had so many Disney sequels
they came and give them fold numbers
anymore
this is Lion King one and a half well
how does that work it's because this
film is a prequel kind of it's focusing
more on Timon and Pumba and where they
came from and all the funny ways they
were interacting through the Lion King
film without us even noticing it
ok concept if you've liked Timon and
Pumbaa which I don't hate him but I
don't know if I want to watch a movie
with these guys the story is not
surprisingly about as generic as it gets
Timon is an outsider among his group and
one day he's put in charge to make sure
the hyenas don't attack of course he
gets distracted the hyenas attack he
feels awful and he has to go find his
own way he ends up leaving coming across
a companion named Pumbaa they form a
bond with both of them being Outsiders
and yeah you just sort of see them
insert themselves in random cliffs some
are funny like when you see what
actually ended that can't wait to be
king song but a lot of them just kind of
seemed pointless you've just kind of
point and go teehee oh that's what was
going on haha and half the time there's
really no connecting story to it when
the story does come back it's okay I
mean there serve a nice connection with
Timon and his mother once in a while
there's an OK laugh but it's so strange
seeing such good animation put to
something that's clearly just kind of an
in-between prequel like I said they call
it one and a half how is a movie called
one and a half given this good animation
the only thing I can figure is because
it is Lion King and that's one of their
biggest property is a kind of figure to
give them the really nice animation
especially when supposed to connect back
to the original film but it's Timon and
Pumbaa why are these great backgrounds
being used for Timon and Pumbaa that is
to say if there was a good story that
went with it like a really great story
that surprised you like Kung Fu Panda or
the lego movie or something that you
didn't think was gonna be phenomenal but
was then I would understand it but it's
just kind of them inserting themselves
into certain parts and not really
flowing at all and I
it just kind of seemed like a mess but
not a god-awful mess it still looked
nice in parts the only thing I can
really say about is if you like Timon
and Pumbaa you'll like this fine it's
basically the Timon and Pumbaa movie I
don't hate Timon and Pumbaa I just don't
feel like watching an entire film
dedicated to all but if you do maybe
you'll like it fine one or two of the
songs are surprisingly kind of catchy
that's where that digging melody is
gonna be my head forever and that's
about it again I think that's all it was
supposed to be I don't know if it's
supposed to be like this grand film or
this grand comedy it's just supposed to
be Timon and Pumbaa being Timon and
Pumbaa and if you like that you'll like
this fine me I think the cartoon show
was a little funnier but yeah I guess if
you're looking for better animation this
is the one to check out keep the watch
and see if it's slimy but satisfying
enough
[Music]
just a heads up everybody the audio on
this might sound a little distorted
because I was actually screaming so much
I blew out the mic I'm sure you'll take
that as a good sign
enjoy
[Music]
okay so I've seen a lot of Disney
sequels this year and I've hated a lot
of them but for some reason some strange
reason Mulan - I hate the most now
that's not saying it's the worst it's
not the worst animated it's not the
worst story the third Beauty and the
Beast probably has that distinction but
something about this one just rubbed me
so the wrong way and got me legitimately
angry which is so strange because the
first Mulan I didn't even get bad into I
mean like dude I thought was fine had
some good moments and stuff
but something about this one just maybe
appreciate it all the more when I see
what it could have been how awful it
could have turned out Mulan is back home
training a bunch of kids how to be
little warrior princesses when her
boyfriend trots by and proposes she of
course says yes but this looks like bad
news for moo shu not voice thank god by
eddie murphy this time but a much more
unfunny Eddie Murphy impersonator who's
going to lose his job because he no
longer has to look after Mulan so it's
up to him to try and split the couple
apart yeah doesn't that make him
incredibly likeable but come on this is
the sequel to Milan this girl that went
and defeated this army surely some
actions got to be in here
well the Emperor of China sees that the
Huns are about to attack okay here we go
now we're gonna get some good sword
fighting he calls a Mulan and was he
ever do its court these three princesses
to be married yeah because a marriage
will unite these two kingdoms and thus
they can fight the Huns together well
wait that's it that's really it
I mean don't get me wrong the movie
makes it very clear early on that isn't
just about fighting and violence it's
about the center and peace and
tranquility of the mind but really this
is the plot of course they bring in the
comic relief from the last film and
they're gonna fall in love with them
there's gonna be this whole thing about
Oh should they may or should they not
you know choose your heart all that bla
bla bla but here's the thing it isn't
like being forced to marry just cause
you're forced to marry because a
tradition the future of China relies on
this that throws in a completely
different element
Mulla doesn't care she just wants her
girlfriend's to be happy but to make
things worse Mushu is constantly trying
to split up the main couple throughout
the entire movie and i mean the entire
movie he suddenly becomes the most
despicable unlikable character in the
world and what makes it even worse is
that it kind of works the boyfriend just
goes off on blonde in this really
uncomfortable animation my god what the
hell's he even doing mulan at some point
through some bullshit realizes that
wasn't true and she's gonna fall in love
with him again and marry him but then he
disappears so she thinks now she has to
marry one of these princes to unite the
two kingdoms the climate every dumb ass
romantic comedy you've ever seen where
the bride is gonna marry the person she
doesn't want to marry and the guy has to
come in confess his love and some sort
of dumb comedic ass happens I'm just
gonna warn you I'm gonna get into
spoiler territory here but I'm sorry
this is really important to talk about
so Mushu tries to make everything better
by telling them that they don't have to
marry well okay
the three princesses marry the man they
wanna la marries the boyfriend but what
about China they're doomed
there's no Alliance the Huns are going
to attack China is officially destroyed
because of this but at least they're
marrying for true love oh it's never
addressed what happens after this I
wouldn't make that make a deal out of it
I know directed Disney sequel haha but
they make a big deal out of it think
you're talking over and over why they
can't get married how thousands will die
if they don't join this union and in the
end I guess they just let thousands die
it's it's really awful there's only one
good song in the whole thing and it's
the first song all the others are either
hand-me-downs or repeats yeah they just
repeat half the songs girl worth
fighting for comes back that'll say from
having to write another paycheck the
animation while smooth and colorful also
kind of looks out of place Milan in the
original had a pretty good range of
emotion but here all the animation is
kind of done like they're comic relief
they're too expressive they're too
rubbery which like I said makes for some
really awkward scenes when the boyfriend
has to yell at her
that's disturbing I don't know what it
is because like I said I didn't get
super into the first film but something
about this was just so insulting and so
demeaning the choices were just so bad
and maybe the fact that they did put in
this really good animation just made the
insult greater if it had the animation
of say Tarzan and Jane or one of these
TV pilots I forgive it a little bit more
but you know that they put in a lot of
effort like yes this is the script
this is gonna be Mulan - this is gonna
be what everyone is gonna get behind I
don't know it's just really friggin err
to me and all the characters are
unlikable and generic and bland and not
interesting or stupid or just
mean-spirited I can't believe what an
asshole moo shu is and the boyfriend and
the lawn for letting the entire
everything of trying to die because
follow your heart which is like oh my
god what is wrong with this movie it is
a mess it is awful it just got under my
skin I hated it so much like I said I
can't say it's officially the worst
there's definitely been worse Disney
sequels but this one so far
I've hated the most it sucks it really
sucks if I ever had a kid and they
wanted to see this I'd say no I just
show him the first Mulan again I don't
even know what to say about it just skip
it don't check it out if you really love
the movie Mulan or even just think it's
okay like I do avoid this at all cost
the only thing it is then made me
appreciate the first one a lot more so I
guess I'll give it that but for
everything else this movie can friggin
blow me
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the more boring scenes from the
original Disney's Tarzan is what he
seemed as a little kid that is to say it
should have been interesting seeing a
half boy half ape trying to figure out
where he belongs should be downright
fascinating but instead it's just some
unfunny slapstick thrown in with
distracting Rosie O'Donnell ape and
aside from a scene where he put some mud
on his face trying to figure out what he
is it's just kind of generic so as you
can imagine I wasn't especially excited
to see Tarzan - which is already falsely
advertised as not Tarzan - it should be
called young Tarzan it's a prequel but
nevertheless I put it in and I'm not
gonna lie I really like this one yeah
not kind of enjoyed that found okay but
was legitimately charmed and entertained
by this cars and - why Tarzan - in fact
101 Dalmatians - why are these the two
Disney sequels so far I think are
actually pretty good these films should
be nothing but they're actually really
delightful the story like I said focuses
on Tarzan when he was a little boy he's
once again finding it hard to fit in and
figure out where he belongs but things
get even tougher when he's separated
from his family and they think he's dead
convinced that his family and his mother
would be better off without him he leads
the tribe to try and figure out where he
belongs along the way he comes across
some colorful characters a pair of
brothers played by Ron Perlman and Brad
Garrett their mother played by Estelle
Harris and an old ape pretending to be a
monster played by George Carlin he
befriends the old ape and makes a deal
that if he keeps convincing everybody
that he's a monster he'll help find out
what he is while that's going on Terk
the elephant and his mother all are
trying to find it while also trying to
escape some beautiful but deadly
landscapes so the important thing to
emphasize about this one is that it is a
smaller story it takes place when he's a
little kid so there's a lot of little
kid stuff there's a lot of slapstick
there's a lot of cute humor but a
slapstick and little kid stuff goes it's
really quite charming
I like these characters I like these two
brothers and their mother and how
they're all kind of dim-witted but
they're kind of threatening to when they
kind of go back and forth I like the old
Abe and the relationship he shares with
Tarzan I like how they both valued the
simple things and they
and to do these nice little things for
each other and I don't know I just
really felt a nice connection between
them and speaking of which that's all
the movie really is it's just watching
these really good connections work off
of each other
most of the voice actors are back except
for the kid roles and that's including
Rosie O'Donnell she doesn't play the
younger version of herself and thank God
because the voice actors they got is a
million times better it sounds like a
real kid and she works off a Tarzan like
a real kid it doesn't feel like a forced
celebrity cameo it feels like there's a
real friendship
the turmoil Tarzan has to go through is
really well done this is the kind of
stuff I wanted to see in the original
movie now don't get me wrong we do get a
little bit of it when he's an adult but
this movie tends to dive more into it
the whole film is about him trying to
find his identity that's his goal that's
the beginning middle and end in the
other movie you got this bad guy who's
trying to kill all the gorillas and you
got him just doing some dumb comedic
stuff with Rosie O'Donnell and yeah I
liked it and it's a bigger story but it
didn't always work there were a lot of
times where it fell short and it felt a
little forced here everything kind of
flows very naturally there's no one bad
guy there's no forced musical numbers
there's no awkward comedy everything
that needs to be done is done perfectly
in serving the story even the Phil
Collins songs which yes there are a few
are scaled down a lot I'm thinking of a
guy here I'm all throughout this movie
and they're gonna piss me off but
there's only a couple when the movie
needs a quiet moment it has a quiet
moment when Tarzan's mom needs to just
sit there missing her son it lets her
sit there and miss her son you don't
need Phil Collins coming out say I'm sad
I'm sad I'm failed Collin okay I know a
lot you like Phil Collins but god I
don't hate Phil Collins I'm sorry if you
want the proof watch this movie the
emotional scenes are so much better
without his damn music I don't
necessarily blame him I blame the fact
that they chose to just go to a Phil
Collins song instead of letting the
story just flow naturally and for a
small quirky kind of movie everything
does really flow here I really get that
Tarzan is trying to figure out who he is
and that's where the focus is
but that doesn't mean there aren't some
funny moments or some quirky characters
or something that's really delightful
now does that make it better than the
first one well first of all it's amazing
I'm asking that at all but that's a
little trickier because the first one is
a bigger story it's supposed to be big
and grand and epic and well this is him
as a kid and supposed to be smaller and
cute but it does it so well that I
really wish it was in the first film and
I get it time constraints you can't do
this but on the other hand I have no
problem believing that this is part of
the story it's not like in Lion King
one-and-a-half where you don't really
believe Timon and Pumbaa we're really
they're doing that stuff they just got
shoehorned it in it really feels like
this was a part of his life growing up
and it's acted well and it's animated
well the drawings unlike Mulan - felt
like they could do the slapstick stuff
well and the emotional stuff just as
great in some respects I would almost
rather watch this than the original
again I'm not saying it's necessarily
better I'm saying it screws up less than
the first one there's so many times in
the first film I remember rolling my
eyes like oh we're doing this thing
dammit we were going so well couldn't we
do this instead of that but here it does
everything that it's supposed to do and
even taking the story that now we've
kind of heard a few times before but the
way they tell it it seems like you're
hearing it for the first time it's like
How to Train Your Dragon yeah we've seen
that setup to death but when it's done
in a unique and passionate way it's
really enjoyable to watch I don't know
I'm still a little too close to it to
declare which one is better but yeah I
actually did kind of like watching this
one a little bit more than the first one
I liked it a great deal and I have no
shame in saying that I like the
characters I like the animation I like
the story I like the backgrounds I like
the acting I like the music it's just
good it's a good Disney sequel I don't
know why it's this and 101 Dalmatians -
but both of these I wouldn't mind seeing
again I'm sure a lot of people are going
to disagree with me and that's fine but
from my point of view this is a movie I
could swing in to watch again
[Music]
it's interesting how we go from a movie
called lilo and stitch to its sequel
stitch to its other sequel called lilo
and stitch - thrown away I do kind of
understand it seeing how stitch was
obviously a pilot to a TV series like
Tarzan and Jane was a pilot to a TV
series but then they come out with
Tarzan - and lilo and Stitch - which
seem more like actual sequels it's also
interesting that these sequels seem to
fall into the slew of smaller stories
they definitely connect to the first one
but they're not is big or grand and well
with the exception of Mulan - there's
surprisingly kind of welcomed
I've enjoyed Tarzan - I thought a lot of
great effort was put into it and here
that's what's not too bad either for the
most part we'll get to the bad stuff -
in this movie stitch has a glitch he
starts acting all evil and attacking
people and doing all sorts of terrible
things but it comes and goes
eventually it's discovered that this
came from a glitch that happened years
ago and the Russian alien is trying to
figure out how to stop it
well that's going on lilo has this big
hula competition that she really wants
to win especially seeing how her mother
won eight years ago and the rest of the
story focuses less on alien encounters
and explosions and ray guns and more on
them just trying to figure out what to
do for their hula contest and keeping
stitch under control like I said a much
smaller movie but for what it is it's
actually alright in the first film I
thought the sisters really stole the
show and in the second film I thought
the aliens really stole the show and
here it seems perfectly balanced both
lilo and Stitch are a ton of fun to
watch they're just adorable I love how
she's written like a real little kid and
that sort of spreads to stitch as well
the side characters though nobody really
knew I'll have fun to watch as well does
that make it as good as the first well
there are a couple problems there's one
or two awkward moments that just come
across as odd for example the Russian
alien knows that stitch has a glitch and
he's trying to put together this device
but he keeps it a secret for some reason
why would he do that should everybody
know that this thing can explode at any
moment and he can attack people and
seriously hurt them or even kill them
why is he keeping it a secret he's
sneaking around trying to get household
items to build this device to save him
but why does he just tell people I'll
tell you why cuz you have to have a
scene where lilo think stitch is really
bad and stitch does feel bad and there
this misunderstanding and it's stupid
it's so friggin stupid
there's also minor things like the
romance between naughty and the
boyfriend is kind of bland once again I
get thing never really got this right
sometimes there's a read from an actor
that clearly needed to be done again and
even the watercolor backgrounds are a
little too obvious this time I don't
know I remember the first family was
blended a little better but here it just
looks super flat and I know that's kind
of the idea of watercolor but I don't
know it doesn't blend as well here
oh and without giving too much away
there is a huge cop-out ending there's a
really emotional moment the acting is
great the animation is great but then
suddenly is just retcon and they never
explain why it's just kind of magic I
guess or is it magic is it science I
don't know it just comes out of nowhere
and they openly admit they don't know
why it happened
stuff like this that could so easily be
fixed is what keeps it from being as
good as the original
but still I'd be lying if I said I
didn't enjoy a lot of it again as
smaller stories go most of the same
actors are back with the exception of
lilo who this time is replaced by Dakota
Fanning and by God she does a great job
impersonating her not just the voice but
the heart the comedy the emotion she
really gets it I don't know if they
switched her out because they want a
bigger celebrity or if the original
actresses voice was changing but she
does a great job you barely even noticed
the difference so even though it's a
sequel that doesn't really add much and
yeah probably doesn't need to exist I
still have a soft spot for lilo and
Stitch and if you do - you'll probably
enjoy this grab your hover ship and
check it out
[Music]
so there's two movies everybody was
warning me about when I was beginning
doing these drug to DVD sequels one was
the third Beauty and the Beast and you
can rightfully see why and the second
was Kronk's New Groove this is one of
the Disney sequels everybody points to
when they want to see how bad they can
get yeah yeah it's not good it's just a
bunch of unfunny stories with unfunny
jokes I guess it's a little difficult to
be offended when it's obviously not
trying that hard I mean don't get me
wrong there's obviously money thrown
into the animation and it moves a lot
but the slapstick is pretty dull the
jokes all fall flat and I just felt like
I watched a whole bunch of nothing the
film centers around the henchmen croc
played by Patrick Warburton he's nervous
because his disapproving father is
coming in to visit and as we go into
three different stories about cat what
were they again the evil villain wants
him back as a henchman of romance that
blooms with a counselor and him trying
to convince his father but he has
everything he's been looking for all of
them are pretty forgettable I guess on
the one hand I can see why people would
be so upset because a lot of people
really like the first movie I just kind
of thought was okay but to its credit it
had a lot more laughs than this movie
does in fact half the movies just trying
to catch in on those laughs again
remember the devil and angel in the
first one they do that like 20 times in
this hell even little kids get an angel
and devil and half the jokes don't make
any sense the devil makes fun of the
angel because he wears a dress
they all wear dresses it's the time
period some of these jokes have great
build-up and then no payoff when Kronk
is about to be reunited with the villain
there's all these jokes about beware the
cat I can't gonna get you and all these
other feline jokes obviously they're
building up that the villain is still
gonna be a cat which is a funny idea
this little cat bossing him around and
trying to do all these evil things
that's funny but no all she has is a
tail how does the humorous that's not
fun
how much funnier would it be if this
whole story happened while she was a cat
a teeny tiny cat that'd be a lot more
humorous on top of that there's a lot of
great talent that they got for this
movie patrick warburton
Eartha Kitt Tracey Ullman John Mahoney
John Goodman these are all funny voices
that belong to fun
actors yet none of them are allowed to
be funny they just kind of show up save
the lines and say them well they're just
not funny lines to say there's even a
totally pointless cameo from David Spade
as the Emperor he literally just comes
in to say he's in the movie nothing else
and he'll come in say a few lines and
then just disappear he'll the way I'm
describing that sounds funnier than how
they actually do it it's just kind of
confusing and awkwardly done the
slapstick is also kind of boring they
just kind of bounce around and move in
the exaggerated ways but it doesn't feel
like there's any focus or control
there's just big movements going on
because that's what kids like to watch
right right so okay obviously this is
not a good movie is it god-awful oh I
don't know I guess it kind of depends
maybe because I've seen so many bad
comedies that really hurt after a joke
is told I don't see this one as
offensive it's kinda like a joke you see
em Family Guy or an Adam Sandler movie
where when it's told and it's bad it's
really bad like you're put in a bad mood
here to its credit the movie seems so
determined to get itself over with as
quickly as possible that the jokes just
kind of fly by they never linger there's
no awkward pauses it just kind of joke
joke joke joke joke and then the movies
done it clearly doesn't have that much
to say or what it does have to say it
doesn't try that hard at so for me it's
just one of those movies that goes in
one ear and out the other
yeah I wish it could have been better
because the villains I thought were the
best part of the first movie but for
what it is it's just bad not the words
not insulting just bad if you have
little kids that just want to see some
cartoons bouncing I guess it's fine but
you're a fan of the Emperor's New Groove
or even not a fan yeah I recommend just
watching a funny Looney Tunes dance away
from this as fast as you can
[Music]
Jesus what is this now the fourth lilo
and Stitch movie this is getting crazy
well thankfully Leroy and Stitch is the
last of these films and I say thankfully
because it actually kind of goes out on
a good note that is to say for what it
is I'm finding out more and more some of
these direct-to-dvd sequels have to be
taken for what they are
for example I'm gonna judge something
like Lion King 2 which is a direct
sequel different lead I am Tarzan and
Jane which is obviously just supposed to
be a pilot for a TV show and at the
beginning of this one you can very
quickly see what it's supposed to be not
a pilot for the TV show but the ending
of the TV show now keep in mind I didn't
watch the cartoon show but I got the
general gist lilo and Stitch are going
around trying to collect all the other
experiments turn them good and stop the
bad aliens from collecting them and
taking over the universe well that's
exactly where this movie starts off lilo
and her friends are being rewarded by
the intergalactic council they're all
given chances to do what they've always
wanted to do whether it be go back to
their evil lab or be captain of their
own spaceship but lilo admits that she's
really gonna miss them and doesn't want
them to leave they decide to stay behind
but she realizes she may have forced
them to make the wrong choice and thus
she finally says goodbye they all go
their separate ways but hamster wheel
the villain of the last kind of sequel
and the villain of the show escapes and
makes a clone of Stitch an evil clone of
course which makes a clone of that clone
and a clone of that clone and soon
there's an army of Leroy's that want to
collect all the experiments that were
set free destroy them all and of course
get back to their evil plans of
conquering the universe much like the
movie pilot Stitch this film focuses
again on the aliens which are once again
very funny below is once again given a
smaller role but I feel they actually do
have the emotional connection there for
example I really like that she becomes
friends with experiment 6 to 5 or is she
now names and Reuben
I like seeing these two work off each
other I also really liked seeing hamster
we only kept out the guard still work
off each other they're still really
funny and unlike a lot of the Disney
sequels it actually builds up to a good
climax you think it's gonna be another
one of those up RuPt happy endings where
it's not really that big of a climax
it's just kind of a tiny one because
heyy they don't have much of a budget
but no they
wipe out all of the clones of Leroy and
have them battle all of the experiments
I'm pretty sure that we're in the show
and all of them look different and sound
different and had these unique powers
and yeah it's really creative it's funny
it's energized it's a lot of fun now
granted what ends up saving the day
might be a little too silly I don't know
it's lilo and stitch I get a kid see
stuff but the battle before was so much
fun I kind of wish it would just keep
going that direction but that's picking
for what is basically a series finale to
a show it seems like it wraps up
everything pretty damn good the original
voice actress of lilo is back again I'm
not really sure why they switched him
out but it's preview and her voice again
the humorous scenes are genuinely
humorous and even the emotional scenes
are kind of well done there's a really
nice scene where everyone is saying
goodbye kind of going their separate
ways and then when Lila has to say
goodbye to stitch all you see is him
looking at the ugly duckling book
putting it away and they just can't sit
there in silence that's actually kind of
profound it's simple but it works and
maybe that's the best way to describe
this simple but it works you can tell
from the animation that this isn't gonna
be the same cinematic quality of the
first film or lilo in stage 2 where they
put a lot more money into it but
honestly for the budget they had I think
they did a really good job does it have
the emotion of the first film no is it
gonna be remembered as much as the first
film no but again I don't think that's
what it was meant to be it's supposed to
be a wrap up of lilo and Stitch yes but
more the TV show than the films and
truth be told this is a really fun
send-off I can't act like it's
phenomenal but for what they had to do
I'd say it's pretty nicely accomplished
again it's one of the nice things of
being forced to watch some of these
movies I'm a lilo and stitch fan but I
never would have checked out the sequels
or these TV pilots if I didn't have to
do this for a job but because I have to
I'm glad I checked them out well none of
them quite capture the freshness or the
emotion of the first one they come
pretty close sometimes and we were
definitely entertaining throughout the
majority of them whether you enjoy the
cinematics side or the television side
it's nice to know that either way lilo
and stitch go out on top
[Music]
so I'm not gonna lie the idea of there
being a Bambi - I surprisingly found
interesting the reason I really liked
the first one I think it's a unique
important even groundbreaking film it's
a movie that lets the art tell a lot of
the story it doesn't have to over
explain it doesn't have to create a bad
guy it's just a little slice of life the
sequel had an interesting premise at
least from my point of view it takes
place literally after Bambi loses his
mother yes boiler alert I think most of
you know that though Bambi's father
requests that somebody else looks after
him because he's gonna be too busy but
the owl suggests that maybe he should
raise him thus the rest of the film is
just watching Bambi grow up with his
father who has never been a parent
before again no complicated stories no
bad guys just a little chunk of this one
life in some respects it's exactly what
I was looking for it's kind of what I
thought I would get kind of what I was
expecting and it's well done on the
other hand though it is a sequel being
made years later to something that was
really unique and always just kind of
did its own thing so the idea of trying
to recreate it years later does feel a
little off it's not something you can
necessarily blame the film for it's just
kind of what's inevitably gonna happen
the artistry is really good this movie
does everything in its power to recreate
the look of the original Bambi and the
feel and the pacing and for the most
part it does a really good job when it
has to look like calming winter it looks
like calming winters when those extreme
colors have to come in with the heavy
shadows there's some how red and blue
and so forth they bring that back too
and it's really effective the
backgrounds are never too crisp either
they're just a little blurred again like
the original film but seeing how they're
using artists and technology years later
you can tell it doesn't quite feel I
don't want to say authentic but a
continuation necessarily you're always
aware they're trying to capture the
magic and the originality of the first
one and that never ever leaves it's
kinda like the sequel to 2001 it's not a
terrible movie but the first one was
just so incredible and just so amazing
that you kinda know you're never gonna
recapture it
and that lingers over the entirety of
the film but on top of that there are
some other problems too one is there are
songs of the time period thrown in and
they are kind of distracting which again
not to act like all the songs in the
original Bambi were timeless but these
really do kind of take you out of the
environment not tars a imbed or return
to Neverland bad but still noticeable
the biggest problem or maybe I should
say pet peeve is the father himself
played by Patrick Stewart a Patrick
Stewart is a perfect choice he sounds
just like the original actor he seems
strong and firm and yeah this is a
really good actor but I guess the way I
always imagined the father was Stern and
strict and didn't really laugh that much
and didn't really show much
vulnerability he was the leader of the
force he couldn't show weakness he had
to be tough all the time so I figured
that would translate over into him being
a parent and while that's what they're
clearly trying to do he does show a
little too much vulnerability he plays
it more like the confused parent the
fish-out-of-water not yuk-yuk or
anything like that but clearly he
doesn't know what he's doing and of
course eventually he lets his guard down
and he goes play with Bambi and has fun
and then he realizes oh he was supposed
to be Stern and strict and yeah it's
just kind of that thing it's not awful
it's just not how I imagined that
character there was so much more mystery
and strength to him when he only said
one or two things when he first sees
Bambi in the first one just stares down
at him and doesn't say a thing that is
so intimidating I thought that was the
father I was going to get but instead we
get lines like a prince doesn't whoo-hoo
me a prince does not a prince walks tall
a prince doesn't show weakened is it
stuff you imagined the mother from brave
saying in my opinion it would have
worked a lot better if they show Bambi
as a child with his father and the
father is strict and Stern and doesn't
show much humanity and then you cut two
years later when he's older then he
confronts the father about why he was so
Stern and strict and the effect it had
on him that seems like a time that Bambi
would talk about it but when he cracks
at his father because he thinks he's
being too mean and he's trying so hard
to be everything you want it just kind
of feels formulaic
and of course the father feels hurt but
can't show the emotion but then he has
to see something that Bambi does that
proves his worth and you know it but
again it's not done bad it is still just
sort of watching Bambi's life and it's
done very similar to how the first film
is a lot of playful moments a lot of
nice artistry a lot of dark moments but
a lot of nice stuff - any problems I
have are kind of nitpicky
for example there's this one dear that's
kind of a bully but he's not the villain
or anything is just kind of a jerky
fragile kid and I think they're building
up that this is the bully that then
confronts him years in the future he
even says at the end one day we'll meet
up again and I'm thinking you didn't
need to make that connection I like that
this was just a jerky deer it's the
forest its nature predators you just
kind of get it there's also a
particularly messed up scene where one
of the hunters in the distance uses a
deer call and it sounds like his mother
mother
[Music]
I didn't know whether I really like this
or found it really silly but it is kind
of disturbing and uncomfortable but in a
good way so overall it is good it just
can't be the first one like I feel it's
trying to be but I really give credit to
the directors and artists and writers
for trying to be the first one they
didn't have to they could just throw
them some directed DVD light animation
Oh Bambi and thumper get in trouble and
just all sorts of bull crap like that
but they do put in the good pacing they
do put in the character they do put in
the artistry they do put in the
suspenseful moments in some respects I
didn't want to know what happened to
Bambi in between those years is kinda
like finding out what happened the
Batman after his parents died he'd kind
of liked it being a mystery but we got
Batman Begins they showed everything
that happened and if it's done well it's
done well this is kind of the same thing
if they are gonna show what happens this
is not a bad version of it I'd say if
you like the first film and are a little
curious to see if this is a good follow
up you'll get an actually okay flick you
can tell a lot of effort went into
trying to capture the voice of the first
one and it doesn't go unappreciated if
you like the first movie in or even the
littlest bit curious about how this one
is I think you might actually like it
okay step out into the meadow and take a
look
[Music]
why was Disney so obsessed with turning
people into bears they did it in brother
bear which didn't do so well it didn't
brother bear - which as far as I know
didn't do so well even Pixar did and
brave which also didn't do so well did
one of the Disney higher-ups just want
to be a bear well whatever the reason we
have this direct-to-dvd sequel that big
shock is not very good if you saw my
review of the first one you know I like
everything in the beginning everything
in the end and think the middle was
really dumb I guess that's better than
this one seeing how it's mostly dumb and
pointless and forced and uncomfortable
and now let's just get to it a young
woman is about to marry a young man in
this arranged marriage but God literally
splits them apart because apparently
they weren't meant for each other
or at least the sassy medicine woman
played by Wanda Sykes says that long ago
she gave her heart to someone else when
they were little kids well of course
that little kid was our main character
from the last one who's a bear now thus
the sassy magic Wanda Sykes gives her
the speech of the bear Oh after he mixed
up with some other wacky animals so now
she can talk with the bear and they have
to work together to burn this amulet of
course they do nothing but bicker and
argue and act like they don't like each
other and where is this going
Shirley they're gonna hate each other
throughout the whole thing right Oh Oh
the sassy little cub from the last one
point it sure is a lot sass in these
movies hates the fact that he might be
falling in love with her so he tries to
jeopardize the relationship but oh oh
the two moods also want to fall in love
with these two lady Moose sis's what's
the plural I don't care it's a dumb
movie will they be able to show them how
to win over the ladies while also acting
cool at the same time oh wait a minute
they're not acting cool they should just
learn to be themselves and follow their
heart and all sorts of other cliches
you've heard a million times but doesn't
add anything new to it that's all it is
it's just cliches from kids movies
romantic comedies bland adventure tales
with nothing charming or fresh thrown on
top of it you're just watching these
cliches play out and nothing else
cliches are fine we need them once in a
while but if you're not gonna add any
thing or giving unique spin on it it's
just cliches and nothing else the world
they inhabit doesn't even make sense
like our right to be knows that the main
character has turned into a bear yet at
the end the cub goes into the village
and they're like oh no they'll kill him
well why would they kill him don't they
know that he's a guy that was turned
into a bear and even when he goes in
there they're all trying to hunt him
down and kill him but she's like no no
no but wait don't they know and on top
of that there's a bear wedding at the
end where there's all these people and
all these animals on both sides clearly
they know why were they hunting each
other a day ago I feel like screw you
guys I'm not going to your wedding bunch
of a-holes all right so yeah this
movie's pretty stupid but is there
anything good to it oh I guess I'll be
enough a couple things one there's no
Phil Collins good start - this is
probably the best-looking out of the
Disney sequels I've seen so far not only
does the animation pretty much look
identical to the first film but the
backgrounds are gorgeous look at those
brush strokes look at how thick they are
they stand out but they also blend
together just right and they really help
the characters in the foreground stick
out well again also kind of blending
together on top of that it also kind of
feels the most cinematic it's paced well
and it's acted well and it's animated
well and it looks great really the
biggest problem is just the writing but
yeah that's a really big problem
it's just characters acting like they
know what to do and then it turns out
they don't know what to do and then they
throw in some catch phrases and look the
Moose says eh like Canadians do because
get it they're from Canada it's just
generic and dumb and doesn't add up I
guess I can't say it's the worst because
we have movies like Mulan too and Beauty
and the Beast three and such to me those
are much more offensive this is just
stupid and once again not deserving of
this great animation and this wonderful
background work I don't know if you're a
fan of the first one maybe you'll like
this one but it's kind of hard for me to
find people are even fans of the first
one they're just kind of forgotten
Disney
movies that for some reason they throw a
lot of effort into just not the best
writing not the worst but definitely
pretty bad
[Music]
Fox in the hound - here we go this is
yet another film that you think of when
you think ooh
crappy direct-to-dvd Disney sequel once
again going back to my original Disney
cember review of Fox and the Hound I
thought it was good no not great but it
had some substance there it was kind of
cute sheep in the same way Bambi was
cutesy and it needed to be and it kind
of tricks kids into thinking it's a
light and fluffy story when suddenly
whoa it's like a really heavy and dark
story but unlike Bambi - they actually
tried to keep that same spirit fucked in
the Hound - it's just an obvious cash-in
that doesn't try at all well for the
most part some of the animation is nice
but yeah that's about it Todd and copper
suddenly see that the CG circus is in
town why is the CG there's no reason
it's just a little cheaper and yeah
that's just kind of how this movie works
copper sees that there's a band called
the singing strays and he decides he was
to join so he tries to sing and they say
hey you have a good voice and seeing how
our other singer just left you can join
our band but the other singer doesn't
like that she was replaced so quickly so
she joins up with Todd who wants to get
his best friend back and says hey why
don't we try to sabotage them so she
shows that copper is not really a stray
hmm and suddenly everything is thrown a
wall and they'll never be able to sing
in the Grand Opera and yeah what the
hell does this have to do with the
original I'm not gonna act like the
original was a classic but by god it had
some weight to it it was about prejudice
it was about seeing past hatred it was
about trying to care for your fellow man
told through this story with a dog and a
fox yeah I know that sounds crazy but
because they really tried they tried to
work with the medium they had in the
story they had and they produce
something that was actually kind of
decent this is crap this is nicely
animated actually too well animated much
better than the original so it's kind of
distracting how well animated it is crap
it's just a knockoff a knockoff that's
not really trying I mean even the idea
Fox in the Hound
unlike Bambi - where there was this
large gap that could be filled in then
could be interesting Bambi with his
father what the hell can you do with Fox
and the Hound - I mean yeah there is
this gap but what's there to fill in
really nothing the two main characters
are separated so there's nothing that
fascinating you could put in there and
even if there was something fascinating
to put in there this team wouldn't put
it in because it doesn't care okay
that's me and I shouldn't say that it
acts like it doesn't care what we get as
a final product just feels like this
cheap corporate shell if your kids like
really bouncy imagery and some music and
just kind of pretty ish animation I mean
it's not really phenomenal but it's
better than average which again kind of
makes me feel bad because why are we
putting this good animation to this this
crappy story this is the Mulan - a Fox
and the Hound sequels I know there's
only one Fox in the Hound sequel but
yeah you can see where I'm going in this
comparison its Mulan - all over again
except with the Fox and the Hound it's
this really decent but somehow misguided
animation that's not given the proper
direction there's not any investment in
the characters honestly there's almost
no reason to call it Fox in the Hound
this could be any characters any
characters could come across this group
of singing strays actually why is it
even a singing stray thing like the
crowd is watching saying wow it almost
sounds like those dogs are really
singing but they are really saying
that's really distracting one like the
owner be like holy fucking shit
I have singing dogs I have to do
something with this but no does he think
it's our record but they're really
singing it makes no sense and I don't
usually think about this but they try to
explain it and they suck at it like
everything in this movie sucks ah I was
trying to think if there was anything
anything in this film that was
redeemable and I guess I thought of one
and a half things
what is the animation yeah it is
decent the one full scene that I
legitimately like is when the owner of
copper and the owner of Todd are both
looking for their pets now these two
don't like each other but they cross
paths and they legitimately wish that
the other find their pets
that's a nice scene that's something
that actually would have been nice to
see in the original it's heartwarming
it's kind of decent aside from that it's
fluff is pure 100% fluff and don't get
me wrong if this movie just wanted to be
fluff if it wanted to be something on
its own and just say hey here's
something for two-year-olds like baby
Einsteins except without the education
that'd be fine but it's not it's the Fox
in the Hound too and when you have that
title you have to have something that at
least is trying to represent the
original and this one is in trying it
has no interest in being the original
Fox and the hound it just wants to make
some fast money look kind of cute and
then disappear well you know what you
did it
you made some fast money you looked cute
and you disappeared whoopty frigging do
I guess I can give it credit that just
like Mulan - it made me appreciate much
more what a good film the original was
now I appreciate what it was doing and
what a great work of prejudice
destroying art it was or maybe this one
was just so bad that I suddenly think
it's a masterpiece in comparison but
either way I guess some good is coming
out of it I'm seeing some more benefit
out of the original Fox in the Hound
that I did before but if you want me to
legitimately save Fox in the Hound to
has something good to offer I say woof
[Music]
Merry Christmas everybody
and on their the occasion I'm gonna take
a little break from the Disney sequels
and instead look at something a bit more
Christmas oriented but is still a
direct-to-dvd movie that's Mickey's once
upon a Christmas every year I see this
brought out and I've never really seen
it before because I think it came out a
little past my time in that I love
Disney but it's kind of the basic Disney
cartoons it's Mickey Donald goofy Oh
learning about the meaning of Christmas
while high jinks ensue I kind of assumed
there wasn't that much adult stuff in it
and yeah it does seem mainly for kids
but for a Christmas movie a mainly at
kids I think it's done pretty good it's
an anthology of stories each dealing
with the holiday the first one centers
around Huey Dewey and Louie and them all
wishing that Christmas could be every
day yeah you know this tale and you kind
of know what comes of it
they get Christmas every day at first
they love it but then they find they
don't and eventually a lesson is learned
it's pretty standard until they throw in
a little bit of a twist where once the
boys get sick of it they start to act up
and make things worse this results in
them seeing the consequences of their
actions on the rest of the family and I
don't know I thought that added a little
bit more at least from what you usually
expect of this story it's kind of nice
and there's a nice little bit about a
Christmas card that you think is the
throwaway joke but it makes a return to
and I don't know it was actually pretty
emotional Anthea I liked it
the second centers around Goofy and his
son Max actually a much younger version
of Max which I really like I can't like
the idea of seeing him at a different
age but then again they pride did that
because it's about his belief in Santa
Claus in that he's starting to doubt
next-door-neighbor Pete tells him that
there's not a Santa Claus so max is
bound to find out if that's true or not
the one bizarre twist is that goofy
believes there's a Santa Claus too it
actually ends up staying out all night
until he comes this one is mostly pretty
good but I don't know I thought the
ending was a bit of a cop-out not to
give anything away but they do reveal
whether he exists in this world or not
and I don't know I thought you could
have done this without a definitive
answer like maybe they go to bed they
wake up in the morning and find the
gifts and then you don't really know if
Goofy did it or if it was just an act I
don't know I felt there was a
really smart good ending to this and
they just kind of do the traditional
route but honestly the rest is so good
especially with max trying to make his
father feel better that I think it's
fine the third and final one starts
Mickey and Mimi re-enacting The Gift of
the Magi yeah they actually call it that
I really think that's cool
I usually don't care from Mickey Mouse
stories but honestly Mickey and Minnie
are kind of the perfect people to tell
this story you all know this tale Mickey
wants to get a gift for Minnie Minnie
wants to get a gift from Mickey but
neither of them have a lot of money so
Mickey has a plan involving his
harmonica and Minnie has a plan
involving her watch and all right I
won't give it away in case you haven't
seen it buddy it's a very decent telling
of the story Mickey and Minnie are the
epitome of wide-eyed innocence that it
really does make sense to do this story
with them it's a good humble telling all
the stories are tied together with a
narration from Kelsey Grammer the minute
you hear his voice doing the whimsical
inspiring thing you just kind of laugh
and giggle at how corny it is but you're
also kind of admire how sweet it is and
that's the best way to describe this
movie corny but sweet the animation is
really good especially considering its
just kind of the Disney cartoons I mean
they didn't have to throw all this money
into it but they did and they really
tried to make it look nice and
Christmassy there's a lot of nice little
touches too if you know the Disney
Universe for example one of these
ornaments is from the second Beauty of
the beast movie Minnie works for
Mortimer's which is this classic Disney
villain even all the characters are kind
of tied into each other like one person
one story might be the neighbor to
another person in another story it's
kind of clever that way there's even a
couple laughs in there there's one
involving goofy finally spotting Santa
Claus that literally made me laugh so
hard and so loud I think my neighbors
walking by heard me I won't give it away
but it was a really funny scene so yeah
this is obviously something meant for
little little kids but there's something
for little little kids go it has a lot
of charm and delight to it it's probably
not something I would put on a lot
around Christmastime but I think it's
great to show your kids and kind of get
in the culture and some of these classic
stories and some news stories as well
with your favorite Disney characters
there's clearly effort that went into it
and the effort pays off you get three
nice gentle stories that are phenomenal
but
each one has a legitimately emotional
moment and each one has one or two lamps
in it as well
definitely a nice one to check out
around the holidays there's plenty more
Disney sequels along the way but until
then Merry Christmas and enjoy the best
day of the year
[Music]
as I get closer to the end of watching
all these Disney sequels I can say that
honestly the most entertaining out of
all of them is Cinderella 3 yeah I know
right the third Cinderella movie that's
ridiculous
look at this opening it doesn't even
look like it's gonna be anything it
looks like a sequel even worse than the
previous sequel but when I was telling
people I was gonna do all these Disney
sequels what I kept hearing over and
over is this Cinderella 3 is good wait
we get to Cinderella 3 that's a good one
and for the most part they're kind of
right are there problems yeah I guess
that's or to be expected with any of the
Disney sequels isn't my favorite no but
again it's how do I put this easily the
most fun like I said before it opens up
kind of corny and chintzy with a goofy
little song not really that impressive
but suddenly the villains return the
stepmother and the stepsisters they come
across the fairy godmothers magic one
turn her to stone and start going back
in time to make it that the stepsister
is the one that has the shoe that fits
thus everything is altered Cinderella's
left in the dust and she doesn't have
her happily ever after the villains are
taken to the palace they hypnotize the
Prince into thinking that the sister was
the one they fell in love with and it's
up to Cinderella to sneak in there and
convince him what's really going on
without getting caught by the guards or
the evil stepmother on the one hand this
sounds incredibly forced and silly and
yeah I guess it kind of is but for such
a forced and silly idea they do
everything that they can with it they
realize that the most interesting
characters are the villains and there's
a lot of time focused on them look at
the drawings on them look at these
close-ups they are just so devious and
they love every second that they're
on-screen and so to weave I remember
there's a scene where Cinderella sneaks
in as a servant then she has her face
covered and the stepmother is sort of
looking in this reflection in the water
and she can kind of see your face and I
actually went oh no which is amazing I
actually said oh no during a Cinderella
film let alone a sequel that's insane
but on top of that they actually give a
lot of characters who didn't have much
development in the other films a lot
more development the King for example is
more than just a guy who's bouncing up
and down saying give me grandchildren
they make him this really sentimental
guy who lost his wife years ago and so
he's passing on this piece of jewelry to
the now daughter-in-law and it's
actually really sweet one of the
stepsisters has given a lot more
development to and what makes us so
clever is that actually ties into the
second film Cinderella - yeah that's
stupid sequel that nobody cared about
they actually has some things that tie
into it not only is her character given
a lot death and a story arc but they
even have characters from the second
film that were introduced in this one as
well remember the woman in charge of the
servants of course you don't because
nobody remembers the second film but
she's in this what an incredible touch
of detail even the prince who had maybe
one line of dialogue in the first movie
and I don't know maybe - in the second
one he was clearly just the eye candy
has a lot more character in this well
okay not a lot more character but
certainly there is a personality there
these general nice and charming but you
do get to know them a little bit more
enough that you want to see him get with
the right person the animation is
fantastic and what's so great about is
that it doesn't necessarily try to
recreate the same animation from the
first film baby to kind of fell into
that trap and well it wasn't really bad
or anything you're just constantly
reminded that this isn't its own thing
this even though it's a sequel does feel
like its own thing the imagery gets a
lot more creepy and a lot more creative
there's a scene where she throws into
relatives giant pumpkins all gross and
disgusting inside and these vines just
grab this horse and wrap around it and
then she turns the cat into this evil
servant who's laughing maniacally as
he's gonna write it off a cliff and it's
just crazy it's something that you want
to see in a fairy tale sequel it gets a
little darker it gets a little crazier
and it gets a lot more fun it's like
half Cinderella and half Tim Burton it's
just so enjoyable to view so okay this
movie sounds great
is it great well there are a few little
problems that hold it back from
being a complete piece and I don't think
it's just nitpicking the biggest one is
Cinderella herself which is not to say
the character is done horribly I mean
they actually animate her very well and
the pacing is good and there's even a
scene when she finds out that
everything's been changed where you
don't even see her reaction you just see
her place her hand on the door and
that's kind of all you need little
moments like that are really really good
but the problem is in the story it's
kind of like The Little Mermaid she
doesn't learn anything she doesn't go
through an arc she just kind of wants to
get something and she gets it I guess
it's just kind of a distracting contrast
when you see what these other characters
are going through and all the changes
that they have going on on top of that
some of the morals are a little weird
like there's this ongoing thing that
when you touch a person's hand you
immediately know if you're in love and
yeah I know Disney fairy tale they kind
of teach even weirder lessons than that
if you really think about it but I don't
know that seemed particularly odd for a
movie that's really trying to fix the
dated problems of the first film it
seems like that was something that was
clearly really distracting that they
maybe should have taken another look at
on top of that this movie has three
climaxes yeah there's one where the
Prince saves her then there's one where
she saves herself and then there's one
where she saves him and it's just kind
of all over the place but they're all
kind of fun too it's like all this green
stuff lying everywhere in this choir
going oh it's something you can clearly
tell the animators and the writers and
the directors were having fun doing and
we feel that fun the hard work and
effort is clearly there in a project
where it didn't need to be there they
went a hundred and ten percent on
something that clearly was just meant to
be thrown out really fast but they
really tried and you can tell they
really tried but yeah those problems I
mentioned before are still legitimate
problems they do kind of focus a little
too much on the side characters and yeah
I know the first film you could argue
that too but the center was still around
her need her want her going through this
endurance to get what was needed working
hard and finally getting that reward
here I guess it's just kind of the same
thing working hard and getting that
reward
we already saw that so why is that
interesting but in my opinion the rest
is so much fun and so crazy and so
enjoyable that I can kind of overlook it
and I think a lot of other people
overlook it too all I can say is what
everyone's been saying about it is
strangely right
it is really entertaining and I highly
recommend it I can't say it's perfect I
can't say it's a Disney classic or
anything but it's just a ton of surreal
joy I like how they took something that
was pretty pointless and even kind of a
dumb idea and turned it into something
that was just kind of cool and focused
on the elements that were the most
enjoyable from the first film if you
want a Disney sequel that doesn't need
to exist but it's still really really
neat
Cinderella 3 is bizarrely enough the one
to check out
[Music]
The Little Mermaid
Ariel's beginning okay that's good kind
of be interesting I mean the animation
looks pretty good and maybe we could see
the backstory of some of these
characters maybe we can see Ursula and
how she got where she was and the
interaction with the sisters and the
father and the mother okay this could be
interesting
it starts off showing Ariel and her
sisters with her mother and father and
suddenly this pirate ship comes out of
nowhere okay
and apparently kills the mother in a
very awkwardly done edit seriously can't
just cut the black this is really
weirdly done but okay let's keep going
so the father is so discouraged by the
death of his wife and the fact that she
loved music so much they decides to
outlaw music throughout the kingdom oh
it's this stupid thing yeah this story
that you've heard a million times it
probably started with Footloose and yeah
wasn't even really good when they did it
then and like that you know every single
damn thing that's gonna happen everybody
said they all want to sing but they
can't sing so Ariel goes and tries to
find out where she can sing but that
conflicts with the father and they get
angry at each other and he's not really
bad he just doesn't see what's really
important and they're gonna butt heads
and then some stupid last-minute villain
is gonna come in try screw everything up
Oh God
no surprises nothing new even have the
songs you've heard before they're just
sort of reworked versions of famous
conga songs in fact how do they know the
song shakes in your eye if they live
underwater that song won't even be
recorded yet okay I'm probably thing to
do hard about that but nevertheless this
is not a very good movie it's not awful
per se I mean it definitely has awful
moments in it but again you can
definitely get an idea that they're
trying to put something decent together
I mean the pacings not that bad it will
take moments to be quiet and sort of let
the emotion sink in they do try to give
the sisters personalities but there are
six of them so it's kind of hard to
remember which ones which and like I
said before the animation is damn
impressive I mean okay we're not gonna
see any Graham landscapes in this or
anything but just look at the line work
look at the expressions look at how
flowing and elegant it is for a
direct-to-dvd movie he'll just for an
animated Disney movie in general it's
really really nicely drawn it's also
interesting to see a movie where not
only the main characters are
good-looking I mean you know how this
works it's usually the male and the
female and they look really pretty
you're handsome and everyone else is
supposed to look cartoony and
over-the-top here
the sisters are in a lot of the film and
they're all drawn beautiful so it's kind
of interesting just seeing these really
good-looking characters throughout the
entire thing it isn't just the main lead
they allow for some nice expressions and
flowing movements and it's like it's it
really really nicely drawn but that
doesn't excuse the fact this is just a
dumb story with dumb writing there's
this villain played by Sally Field who's
kind of a servant of the king looks
after the girls and sort of wants to be
the second-in-command what's in a while
she'll get a laugh I meet Sally Field
can be very funny but to answer the
question that everybody is thinking
including myself no it's not Ursula
wait a minute in the first film she
describes herself that she used to be in
the palace and then she did these evil
things and she was thrown out that's
exactly what this character does and
even kind of looks like a younger
skinnier version I mean why why wasn't
this Ursula she even has cure eels that
go after the heroes it was so obviously
meant to be Ursula I was waiting the
whole time to see some sort of magic
zapped her she was transformed or
something or they give her a new name
like Ursula is actually a demeaning name
and that's what you'll be called now or
something but no it's just a completely
different character that has Ursula's
backstory come on you've got a Sally
Field play a young Ursula we won't have
minded so yeah the movies praise to do
it but it makes no sense I guess if you
just have little kids that want to see
it just to see nice music and Ariel
swimming around looking pretty it's fine
for that it's not like Beauty and the
Beast 3 or Mulan to where there's
arguably bad stuff for kids in it I mean
it's harmless but it's also mindless
nothing in it is original every line
every plot thread you can point to a
million other movies that have not only
done it but have done it better I guess
it's fine if you just want to track your
kids for an hour and a half but anyone
looking for the magic of the original
this one's dead in the water
[Music]
well I looked at the first one only
figures to look at the sequel during
this sequel month its Mickey's twice
upon a Christmas and you know when
people ask what's the difference between
something that's good for kids yet not
necessarily for adults or bad for kids
and not necessarily for adults either
this is a perfect example the first once
upon a Christmas was a simple but humble
and sweet story it was expressive it was
kind it was a little corny but the
effort really shows and pays off this is
a cash-in you can smell from a mile away
just look at it I mean look at it
I know it's direct-to-dvd so the CGI
isn't gonna be like Pixar quality but
look at it the first one was
direct-to-dvd - and you can see all the
great drawings all the great atmosphere
expressions it was impressive by its own
standards this even by its own standards
it's cheap looking and lame and not
written well and heartless and empty and
just like I said I'm obvious Kashyap
okay well I guess I should go over all
the stories but that almost seems
pointless because we're in the first
film it was only three stories that
seemed reasonable enough this one it's
like eight yeah
they just throw a bunch of oh man -
whether they make sense or not it
becomes so much overload that the
motivations aren't even established when
the story start the very first story is
just Daisy and Minnie skating well okay
that's fine but for whatever reason
Daisy tries to sabotage Minnie was that
in her character is that something she's
known for
I can see Donald doing that but nothing
about her has ever been established as
this egotistical jealous character and
that many gets really angry - and she
starts fighting back and it's just this
entirely pointless number here's another
kind of mean-spirited story where Donald
comes home from work he's really tired
he just wants to relax but then Daisy
and the boys all want to go Christmas
shopping and they force him to come with
he gets angry because Christmas is being
shoved in his face a just needs a break
from it but he shouldn't be he's wrong
much like Christmas with the Kranks you
should just accept everything about
Christmas and love it all
unconditionally seems like a very
confused message
and I can kinda see what they're going
for like you're just gonna need that
extra effort to make Christmas special
for your kids and your loved ones and
stuff but first of all there is nephews
not as kids I still don't know where the
damn parents are second you sympathize
too much for him I wanted to be by the
fireplace I wanted to have his hot
chocolate I don't want to go out to the
store and have all this commercialism
shoved in his face
somewhere there's a sweet nice idea
trying to get out bites just lost
there's also this lame number about max
bringing his girlfriend to meet his dad
and most of it's a pop song that he's
not really singing yeah he never sees
lips move and the song doesn't really
match the atmosphere they're trying to
make it sound like one of those songs
you can hear on the radio but it's not
even vague enough to be a song that you
can hear on the radio they're obviously
saying the dad's gonna embarrass me I
hope he doesn't embarrass me around
Christmas they can't even get whoring
the fake pop song right nobody would
listen to this on their own but the
characters clearly not singing the song
either so it's just entirely confused
remember how Santa Claus was a big deal
in the first one like goofy and Max were
trying to believe but they didn't know
if they did but they wanted to believe
that was a whole big thing in this 1ue
doing Louie just mail themselves to
Santa yeah I guess he's not really that
big a deal anymore and look at him talk
about the most generic forgettable Santa
you can imagine rere are there any good
things about this special I guess the
colors can be kind of nice and
Christmasy every once in a while there
is a good visual joke or a line here
there but for the most part it just
feels shallow I guess it seems silly to
be this hard on a little Christmas
special that's obviously just meant for
little kids but the first one was just a
little Christmas special meant for
little kids and they really did a much
better job they cared they took the time
to write good stories and putting good
animation because it felt like the
respect of the audience was important
they know they can show little kids
anything with Donald and Goofy and
Mickey and stuff but instead they tried
to give something really nice and
meaningful and that's felt by the adults
as well as the children this just feels
like what it most likely is a
last-minute sequel the first one
probably made a lot of money so they had
to squeeze out a sequel and this is what
we
a cheap knockoff with little to no heart
I can't say it's as bad as some of
Disney's other worse anime of films I
mean I can't say it's Chicken Little or
home on the range or move on to but it
just feels lazy and don't get me wrong I
don't know how much time or money they
had to put into this so I shouldn't
judge but it's just how it feels it
feels lazy can you show it to kids
sure does it get across any
mean-spirited or bad morals little
debatable but none that little kids will
probably get it's just a weak Christmas
cash grab and nothing more if your kids
really dying to see it I guess it's okay
to show but in my opinion die just put
on the first one again
[Music]
well I've already reviewed a ton of
direct-to-dvd sequels why not review
this one Inspector Gadget - yeah kind of
an Inspector Gadget filled month isn't
it this is a follow-up to the first film
starring Matthew Broderick and though
it's not nearly as bad hell you just
subtract Matthew project from it it's
immediately better it's still pretty bad
this time inspector catch is played by
French Stewart of third Rock from the
Sun Fame at first you think it's gonna
be exactly like the first one with its
awkward style and weird in-your-face of
facts that really really suck even more
this time but as it goes on it calms
down a bit as it tries to squeeze
historian Inspector Gadget is having a
bunch of glitches and his nice penny now
in high school it's starting to notice
and tells him to go get a fixed his
inventor however has an even better plan
make a brand new gadget Entergy - an
updated version of gadget who seems to
be a better officer in every way not
only having no glitches but no human
parts at all that's right she's 100%
machine and as soon as Inspector Gadget
hears that he falls immediately in love
yeah that's kind of weird / creepy she
does the typical robot stuff doesn't
understand human emotion talks like this
all the time battle jazz but give her
credit it's a lot more interesting than
dr. claw escaping only this time it's
not played by Rupert Everett and this
time you don't see his face well okay is
sorta you see his mouth and his know
sometimes you see his eyes actually you
kinda do see his face but they at least
make it attempt to hide it this time is
played by some old guy with a really
weird voice that sounds nothing like the
original claw but he has the claw from
the first movie but you don't see his
face like the cartoon it's really kind
of confusing but at least we see penny
snooping around with her dog brain and
she has the little watch and no computer
book but she has the watch and they give
her a kind of bigger part then it's
weird because she'll tell brain to look
after gadget but you know he's a dog
like a real dog so he can't do anything
like what he does in the cartoon and
what is this movie trying to be the sad
desperate souls they actually like the
first film aren't gonna connect that
much with it like I said gadgets differ
Penny's different dr. claw is really
different and the fans of the cartoon
are gonna like a few things change but
it's still clearly not trying hard
enough to be the cartoon it's almost
like the filmmakers got all these really
angry notes and they said oh okay we're
not supposed to see claws phase Penny
supposed to snoop around brain supposed
to help okay
we'll do that but then for some reason
they still never looked at the cartoon
they didn't see how you're supposed to
do it
don't get me wrong the cartoons weird I
think it's kind of debatable whether or
not it's actually even good but it was
kind of entertaining and interesting and
had kind of its own unique formula and
its own kind of awkward charm this
doesn't well French Stuart is definitely
a better gadget than Matthew Broderick
he still doesn't seem like he's being
told the right things to do
that's to say comedic Lee his line
delivery just seems off it doesn't sound
like he's trying to impersonate Dada
Adams or do his own thing it's just kind
of weird all my years of crime-fighting
gadgetmobile is that it's always the
most quiet on top of that a lot of the
comedy is off every once awhile I get a
little bit of a giggle like I like how
the bad guys are sneaking in as this
band and none of the instruments they're
playing matches the music that's being
played behind them on an obvious
recording in fact it's sitar music and
there's not even a sitar in there
that's funny once in a while you'll get
a little moment like that the effects
are really awful at the very least in
the first film they tried to make some
practical effects with the CG here it's
all CG and it's we don't give a crap CG
look at this scene where this rope is
supposed to wrap around gadget what the
hell am I even looking at it looks like
one of those old Marvel hologram cards
it doesn't even look solid the acting
pretty much from everybody either ranges
from bad to just off I don't know what
direction they were given but it was
always kind of the wrong direction
everyone says their lines just a little
strangely and that's already made odd by
the fact that they already have strange
voices the only time the acting does
work a little bit is when French Stewart
has to have an emotional moment I know
that sounds strange and there aren't
that many of them but when he genuinely
seems confused or sad or
it's done in such a brainless way that
he's still gonna seem sympathetic I
can't explain it there's something
weirdly genuine about it aside from that
I don't know what this film is going for
it'll have the little mad logo like from
the cartoon but even that looks a little
different why you have the rights to
Inspector Gadget just go all out there
so okay is it as bad as the first one
no there's very few things that are as
bad as the first one the first one was
painful the first one every single time
a joke was made or somebody gave a weird
look it hurt the first film hurt this
film doesn't hurt it's just dumb it's a
dumb movie it'll probably be forgotten
the minute you watch it the first film
leaves scars scars that will never heal
this is just a lame flick so for some
reason your kid wants to see it you can
go ahead and show it there's nothing
that's gonna screw em up but for anyone
else if you have any interest in seeing
this movie go-go-gadget
don't
[Music]
ever since the movie Toy Story came out
I as well as I'm assuming a lot of other
people really wanted a Buzz Lightyear
show everything he described about his
world just sounded so much fun flying
through space defeating the evil Emperor
Zurg fighting aliens blasting things
blowing them up it sounded like a show
that practically wrote itself
well Buzz Lightyear a Star Command was
the pilot film to get that show going
and as pilot films go it is pretty much
just an hour and a half long Saturday
morning cartoon but I mean that in all
the best ways it opens with the Toy
Story characters actually watching it on
the TV as if to already set up hey this
is meant to be like a Saturday morning
cartoon and that's exactly how it plays
out
in the movie Buzz Lightyear played again
by Tim Allen is off again to fight the
evil Emperor Zurg Zerg wants to get this
technology known as the Uni mind it's a
device that the L GM's you can guess
what that stands for
use to communicate with one another to
become the most efficient race ever but
sir-- captures the device and plans to
use it for evil turning everybody's
minds as diabolical as his so it's up to
buzz of course to go in and stop him but
the one downside is they wanted to have
a partner but of course he doesn't want
a partner why because he lost his last
partner warp and the pain was just too
near and so of course he turns away the
others that try to come to his side a
ranger named Nova who's also a princess
but doesn't like being a princess a
bumbling janitor who has dreams of
adventure and a nerdy robot who always
has those clever one-liners this setup
is of course about as stock as you can
get but the thing is with the way it's
written it's aware that it's doc and it
has fun with it there's a lot of great
comedic talent behind these characters
including Nicole Sullivan Larry Miller
and Wayne Knight who's practically
unrecognizable as ergh I think they're
distorting his voice a little bit but
whatever they're doing they make it
sound great
it's but kind of menacing but super
hilarious at the same time you're
telling
I already know my plan the atmosphere
gives you what you're looking for with
space men and women traveling through
space and shooting up aliens but it also
has this clever side to it
Rangers condition status excellent let's
roll the comedy is both mocking but kind
of paying homage to these sort of 80s
Saturday morning tropes like the climax
is stopping xored from pointing his
death ray to the planet of orphans and
widows there's like a five-minute
conversation decade to getting nose rigs
why can't we have nose rings
because nose rings of our punks little
mister well if you can take on Zerg
alone I don't see why XR can't get a
nose ring I was just asking a question
I'm not the one getting a nose ring and
all these characters egos do great at
working off of each other trying to show
off trying to be funny and ultimately
succeeding at the end but just barely
it doesn't really have any twists or
surprises or at least nothing you can't
see coming a mile away but again it
feels like that's the intention it's
trying to give us that silly version of
transformers or Thundercats or
Silverhawks except there's a
self-awareness that makes for a lot of
funny comedy I'd say the one nitpick I
have in the entire thing is that booster
the big janitor guy he doesn't really
seem to have a point the other cadets
definitely proved their worth but this
guy just sort of acts afraid and screams
and I don't know I get what he was there
as the scaredy-cat character but I
didn't really get why he was there in
terms of the story but again story is
not a big thing here what is big is the
adventure the comedy the characters and
they all do great delicate in that
cheesy Saturday morning way that they're
obviously going for if I was a little
kid I would love this this is the exact
show I would want to see looking at Buzz
Lightyear in Toy Story it feels like
this is the show the toy was based on
these were the adventures that they made
him out of it say if you had even the
tiniest interest in seeing this at all
like I said obviously for kids but it
has just the right amount of comedy
Chanin charm give it a watch and have
fun going to infinity and beyond
[Music]
Mickey Mouse in the three musketeers
that is pretty much exactly what you get
Mickey Donald and Goofy all going off to
save princess Minnie so that evil
captain Pete can't take over the crown
as somehow connecting her makes him King
this is a really story based the plot is
wait no that was pretty much it yeah
that's about as generic and
old-fashioned a cartoon plot for kids
goes so is it any good
it's hard to pick on something that's
obviously meant for like little little
kids I mean it's a Mickey Mouse
direct-to-dvd movie what do you expect
but again I guess it's not fair Mickey's
bad some really good stuff there's a
great short he was in called the Prince
of the pauper Fantasia is a masterpiece
even that Mickey's once upon Christmas
had a lot of charm to it this I don't
really describe as having a lot of charm
but it's a harmless every character and
motivation is exactly what you think
it's gonna be Mickey is optimistic but
he dreams of being a Mouseketeer
I really just say that you know what I
mean goofy is a doofus but he wants to
apply his brain Donald is a coward and
wants to learn how to be brave and many
as a princess oh of course he wants to
fall in love there is nothing new or
original in this even the songs are
classical public-domain tunes that they
just put lyrics to some of them already
have lyrics they just add new ones
I guess it's good this teaches kids
classical music but it's music you're
gonna hear everywhere anyway I don't
know the animation is clearly trying and
the backgrounds are clearly trying but
nothing really stands out as great
everybody does exactly what you think
they do everybody reacts exactly how you
think they'd react so why doesn't this
work as well as say the Buzz Lightyear
cartoon well that one's still through in
some good laughs and it was creative it
had kind of a goofy story but it also
had some imagination to it the best way
I can describe this one is by looking at
the opening and closing credits you see
this comic strip style this was very
popular back in the day in fact these
Mickey Mouse comics are kind of these
rarities they're seen as this pure
innocent artwork of more simple times
they didn't have much depth in fact they
had virtually no death
they were so simple and colorful that
kids really loved it and it's our
carried over for some adults this is
pretty much the same thing it's innocent
it's harmless but I don't really see any
reason to watch it either it's fine for
kids I guess but aside from the
smoothness of the animation and some of
the backgrounds
nothing really screams Disney top of the
game but again it's a direct-to-dvd
Mickey Mouse movie but again more effort
has been put into those in the past but
again it's not like no effort was put
into this but I'm priming is more
complicated than it needs to be if
you're an adult it's unlikely you'll get
into it at all well if you're a little
little kid that just wants to see Mickey
Mouse go on an adventure
it's energized colorful and harmless
don't expect anything great but honestly
you probably weren't anyway you're
probably just expecting a Mickey Mouse
cartoon and that's what you get a really
long Mickey Mouse cartoon five for
little boys and girls but that's really
about it it's all for one and one for
[Music]
let's finish up Disney cember with
Tinker Bell yeah there's a strange while
where Tinker Bell was extremely popular
it's weird because the character has
been around for years and years but only
now did the popularity just explode was
this movie the cause of it maybe it
opens literally with Tinker Bell's birth
which is kind of like what they say in
the book where a child laughs that
laughs goes to Neverland and then
suddenly a fairy is born only she's not
born like a little baby she's born fully
grown I guess it's like Pinocchio where
the personality is just intact oh why am
i analyzing it it's fairy tales and this
is obviously made for little kids who
just want to see Tinker Bell fly around
look pretty do some magic and yeah
that's about it the story is pretty
standard but you can tell it's written
for little children Tinker Bell is
looking for her place to belong and
she's put with the tinker fairies yeah
who would have thought Tinker Bell is
really good at tinkering putting things
together figuring out gears and such
unfortunately the over inventions don't
always work out that well and that means
that she can join the group of fairies
that leave Neverland and go into the
other world
so Tinker Bell gets a group of fairies
together and tries to have them teach
her how to do various other things that
can get her into the other world
unfortunately she doesn't seem very good
at it she's only good at tinkering and
making stuff and even then she's not
that great either through hard work and
determination she will make everything
really bad yeah it's one of those
stories where she screws up everything
for everyone but she also finds a way to
make it better in the end and a nice
little compromise is made actually that
is one of the few things I really admire
about this movie the message of
compromise that is to say
Tinker Bell eventually comes to terms
with her gifts but she also pushes
really hard to get what she wants and
what she feels is rightfully hers I
Meyer films like wreck-it Ralph or
Nightmare Before Christmas that sort of
say just be happy with what you have but
also like stories like this where it's
be happy with what you have but don't be
afraid to go a little further to fight
for what you really want sometimes you
get it sometimes you don't and sometimes
it's halfway in between like what we
have here but is there anything really
that gripping for adults in this not
especially this is something that's
written for little little kids but for
little little kids it's innocent enough
it definitely has a visual style some of
the backgrounds are very nice everyday
items they use from
hours and raindrops and such are pretty
clever and the movie is trying to have a
certain weight to it the music
especially is trying to give this grand
choir going on make it seem really huge
and you know what it's allowed I mean
look at this animation style this is
clearly trying a lot harder than
something like twice upon a Christmas
they want it to look whimsical they
wanted to feel like these characters are
alive and for the most part they do a
good job outside of that there's not
really that much to get into for adults
although I do love this one scene when
she's testing her equipment oh does that
crack me up so much but aside from that
it's not incredibly smart but it's not
incredibly dumb either it's a nice
little innocent film to show your kids
and they'll get some creativity there
are slow moments there's times where
they need the emotion to set in but
there's also fast moments on their
scenes where they throw in the little
pop song and such I'm definitely not
gonna put it on anytime soon but if I
had little kids and they want to watch
this I'd say it's a good thing to put on
I don't have nearly enough time to look
at the dozens of sequels that came out
afterwards I know it's ironic seeing how
this was sequel month but like the movie
said compromise it's a good thing and
with that said that wraps up Disney
cember with the direct-to-dvd sequels
was it as bad as I thought it was gonna
be well in some areas it was even worse
but in some areas it was actually okay
and surprisingly in others I found
myself having a good time you can
definitely tell which films were just
rushed out and they didn't really care
about and which ones they wanted to put
the extra time and effort into even when
they didn't need to put in the extra
time and effort I'm a cat like any of
these were great but I was shocked to
find those couple they were actually you
know not only tolerable but some
legitimately entertaining they were few
but I've respected them and the ones
that were bad like really bad
well they'll bring us a lot of laughs in
mockery and just how awful they are at
least I can say I saw them all and I
gave them a fair shot and though I was
shocked with how bad some of them were I
was shocked by how good some of them
were I guess sometimes even when a
company like Disney just wants to throw
their table scraps at us you can
actually take those table scraps and
turn it into a good meal it doesn't
happen all the time but
enough times to get noticed folks I hope
you enjoyed this year's Disney cember
and if you're like me you're
anticipating what Disney has next to
offer thanks for watching and I'll see
you next year
you
[Music]